Guten Morgen Linus!
Guten Morgen, Khaleesi.
Sag mal Linus, was ist eigentlich deine Lieblingszahl?
Auf jeden Fall eine Primzahl.
52 vom 31. Januar 2023. Tim ist diesmal nicht da, dafür bin ich da. Und nein, es ist nicht so, dass Tim und ich uns verschritten haben. Nein, wir waren ja auch in der letzten Sendung gemeinsam
zu hören. Aber Tim wird heute vertreten von Calisi, die ja sonst gerne mal mich vertritt.
Also heute mal eine ganz neue Herausforderung für dich, Khaleesi.
Ja, gucken wir mal, wie wir so miteinander klarkommen.
Okay, alles klar. Schon mal die Krallen gezeigt. Wir werden sehen, wie das jetzt hier weitergeht. Ich gebe mir Mühe.
Ich gebe mir Mühe, okay? Also sei nachsichtig mit mir.
Ja, ich meine, sonst vertrete ich euch einfach nicht mehr, das wäre ja auch ein Problem.
Ja, das wäre schlecht. Vielleicht irgendwann könntest du und Thomas uns mal ganz vertreten, dann können Tim und ich mal zusammen Urlaub machen.
Die Frage ist, wie viel EU-Politik halten die Hörerinnen aus?
Das stimmt, da müssen wir aufpassen.
Aber vielleicht hier ein bisschen Logbuch Netzpolitik auch mal ein bisschen über die,
Bundesgrenzen hinaus wachsen zu lassen. Wenn ihr uns ordentlich Hörerinnen in Luxemburg, Österreich, Schweiz organisieren könntet, dann können wir da mal drüber nachdenken.
In Brüssel werden wir ja schon sehr viel gehört, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Tatsächlich melden sich Politikerinnen doch relativ häufig und vielleicht noch mehr aus Berlin als aus Brüssel.
Aber genau deswegen, dafür haben wir ja Thomas und ich da, um dort auch unsere Kontrolle über die ganze Bande ein bisschen weiter auszubauen.
Unsere Ablehnung zu kommunizieren.
Ja, genau, unser fundamentales Besserwissen und Bessermachen lassen. Wir haben ein bisschen Feedback zur letzten Sendung, und zwar einmal von Fussel vom CCC
Freiburg. Kleine Ergänzung zur Hausdurchsuchung bei Radio Dreieckland. Ihr erinnert euch, ein kleiner Einweis von uns.
Der Dreiklang war der Freiburger Radiosender, der durchs Haus durchsucht wurde an mehreren Orten, weil sie einen Link auf ein Archiv von links unten in die Media hatten.
Dazu also der Kommentar. Konstruiert würde man den Radiomachenden unterstellen, sie unterstützten damit einen verbotenen Verein.
Das übrigens ist ein Konstrukt, das nie wieder weggehen wird, weil das nur Betroffene machen,
können. haben Sicherheitsbehörden hier einen Hausdurchsuchungsjoker erfunden. Bis in alle Ewigkeit reicht damit die bloße Unterstützung, man betreibe eine Nachfolgeorganisation oder ein Unterstützerkreis des verbotenen,
Vereins rechtstaatlich auch irgendwie eine Bankrotterklärung.
Soweit bekannt war der Staatsanwalt daran beteiligt, eben genau jener, der bis dahin alle anderen Links-Unten-Verfahren verloren hat. Also der gleiche Staatsanwalt, der sich den ganzen
bis damals aus, oder der den ganzen bis damals umgesetzt hat. Das Verbot von Links-Unten ging ja meintlich aus vom Innenministerium. Der Staatsanwalt, der das dann nicht weit genug tragen konnte,
hat dann auch diese Hauswisssuchung gemacht. Das wäre natürlich klug gewesen, wenn der Herr
gräulich sich ein neues Problem in Freiburg gesucht hätte. Aber ein Problem scheint Freiburg generell armer zu sein. Übrigens gibt es zu dem Thema, Radio Dreiklang hat das dann direkt,
weiterverwendet, dieses Thema und hat dann mit Fussel ein Interview geführt über Hausdurchsuchung und Schutz digitaler Geräte. Auch das haben wir mal in den Show Notes verlinkt.
Oh man, ein Hausdurchsuchungs-Stoker, das finde ich auch eine schöne Wortneuschöpfung.
Und apropos Wortneuschöpfung, du hast ja jetzt auch die neuste Primzahl erfunden in der letzten,
Folge. Aber es ist gar keine Primzahl, Linus. Hast du da in Mathe nicht aufgepasst oder was ist da passiert? Aber die Kommentare haben es ja dann nochmal sehr schön aufgearbeitet in unterschiedlichen Formen. Ich finde das ja auch manchmal ganz gut, wenn einem das unterschiedlich erklärt wird, bis man's dann verstanden hat.
Also ich gebe zu, die Rolle der Eins als Primzahl ist umstritten.
Wir haben aber immerhin eine, das fand ich sehr elegant, eine Primzahl an Kommentaren, die mich darauf hinweist, nämlich 17 Stück an der Zahl.
Und einige haben sich, glaube ich, auch gewundert, warum so viele das kommentiert haben. Und da muss ich zugeben.
Also nicht alle haben das kommentiert und wussten dabei, dass es schon was war, was ich 10, 20, 17 Leute vor ihm kommentiert hatten, sondern wir haben aus Gründen eine kleine
Regel, dass wenn ein Kommentar von jemandem kommt, der oder die noch nie kommentiert hat.
Landet sie in der Moderationsschleife. Also der Kommentar wird nicht sofort freigeschaltet.
Das hat sich als relativ gute Moderationsregel erwiesen, weil relativ selten jemand in der Moderationsschleife landet, dann auch nur einmal. Und einige, die dann da eben zurecht,
landen, nie das Licht der Welt erblicken. Ich habe da immer einen Vortrag zugehalten, die Trolldrossel, einige erinnern sich. So kam es, dass eben relativ viele das kommentiert haben,
in relativ kurzer Zeit, ohne zu sehen, dass es schon andere kommentiert hatten. Und daher
kommt diese hohe Anzahl an Hinweisen auf diesen Sachverhalt. Und der letzte Kommentar dazu, den fand ich dann auch echt Herz allerliebst von Cantorkel. Hallo, ich melde mich schon lange und
ich wollte auch noch mal sagen, also die 1 ist gar keine Primzahl, fand ich sehr gelungen. Und zwar ist sie keine Primzahl, weil die Definition einer Primzahl ist, dass sie nur
durch sich selbst und 1 teilbar ist. Und die 1 ist nur durch sich selbst oder durch 1 teilbar,
weil man jede 1 von dem 1 mal 1 nur einmal zählen darf. Und deswegen ist 1 keine Primzahl.
Das würde, glaube ich, auch des Weiteren die Aufgabe der Primfaktorzerlegung immer relativ simpel machen, wenn man die 1 immer nehmen dürfte.
Aber okay, ich gebe mich geschlagen, 1 ist keine Primzahl, aber trotzdem war das ein wichtiges Datum.
Auf jeden Fall.
23.1.23.
Ja. Definitiv. Ich weiß gar nicht, was da war, aber es war auf jeden Fall bestimmt ein wichtiges Datum.
Letzte Sendung. Zum ersten Mal, zum ersten Mal. Das ist ein Thema, über das wir uns eigentlich sonst.
Ja, gut. Okay. In der letzten Sendung habt ihr ja auch über Mobilfunkabdeckung gesprochen und dazu gab es auch...
Noch nie aufgeregt haben.
Nee, gar nicht. Das war mir auch noch nie aufgefallen. Also ich habe immer noch genauso wenig Ahnung von Mobilfunkabdeckung wie vor sechs Jahren oder so. Genauso wie die Bundesregierung.
Dazu gab es auf jeden Fall einen Kommentar von Jörn, der schreibt zu Funklöchern und Mobilfunkabdeckung nach Haushalten. Ich habe in meiner Familie eine Lehrerin, die während des Corona-Home-Schoolings feststellen musste, dass die Familien ihrer Schülerinnen, die,
mit knappen Mitteln haushalten müssen, häufig nur über Mobilverträge verfügen und auf
einen festen Internetanschluss aus Kostengründen verzichten. Im normalen Alltag kamen die damit,
wohl ganz gut aus, da das mobile Internet unterwegs benötigt wird, aber halt auch,
zu Hause nutzbar ist. Spart also um die 40 Euro monatlich. Mit Zoom, ETC, kam das dann
aber im ländlichen Niedersachsen an seine Grenzen. Unter dem Gesichtspunkt hat die Abdeckung,
der mobilen Internetverfügbarkeit nach Haushalten also tatsächlich einen Sinn. Auch, wenn das,
meiner Meinung nach nicht so sein sollte, ist ein Internetanschluss zu Hause leider,
auch heute noch keine Selbstverständlichkeit. Ansonsten gehe ich natürlich dabei mit, dass dass die Messung der Abdeckung mit mobilen Internet anhand von Haushalten Quatsch ist.
Ja, dazu, also das Problem stimmt und das haben wir, glaube ich, auch ausführlich besprochen
und also dem allen, kein Widerspruch von meiner Seite, mehr Volumen muss her und mehr Unterstützung für Menschen geringen Einkommens auch an diese Form der unerlässlichen digitalen sozialen
Teilhabe zu ermöglichen. Allerdings muss ich einen kleinen Hinweis machen an dieser Stelle.
Dass die Mobilfunk-Anbieter Haushalte versorgen. Das machen die schon von sich aus. Also das ist ja quasi, wenn ich denen sage, baut Mobilfunk-Netz, dann werden die das dort bauen, wo die meisten
Menschen sind. Die meisten Menschen sind in Städten und also bauen sie es dorthin. Das ist immer das erste, was ausgebaut wird. Wenn jemand ein neues Mobilfunknetz baut oder eine neue Mobilfunknetzgeneration ausrollt, dann machen sie das was, was ich in Berlin, Frankfurt, Düsseldorf,
wo auch immer, München, Hamburg, wo auch immer viele Menschen sich versammeln und nicht in
Klesengörne. Und das ist aber genau der Punkt, dass man ja in der Regulation im Prinzip den den Zwang dahin setzen muss, wo sie nicht von alleine hingehen.
Und wenn ich also sage, okay, passt auf, ihr müsst 98 Prozent der Haushalte versorgen, dann ist das ein sehr viel niedrigschwelligeres Ziel, als wenn ich sage, ihr müsst 98 Prozent der Fläche versorgen.
Dass wenn ich sage, 98 Prozent der Fläche oder 95 Prozent der Fläche oder was auch immer,
dass dann in diesem Bereich die Städte und Haushalte versorgt sind, dafür sorgen die schon von alleine.
Und solange wir nicht anfangen, die Bahngleise zu besiedeln, gibt es dann da eben kein Netz.
Und das ist genau der Unterschied. Die Regulierung muss ja idealerweise über das hinausgehen oder die Unternehmen zu dem zwingen, was sie nicht von alleine tun.
Und aus dem Grund macht quasi die Vorgabe versorgt Haushalte keinen Sinn, weil das würden sie auf jeden Fall sowieso machen. wenn Sie diese Vorgabe nicht hätten, sagen, komm, lass uns das irgendwo hinbauen, wo keiner wohnt.
Insofern, regulatorisch bleibe ich dabei. Flächenabdeckung oder von mir aus, kann man auch sagen, Straßen, wo Menschen sind, Autobahnen, Landstraßen oder was auch immer zu versorgen.
Aber das Ergebnis der Vorgaben, die wir jetzt haben, sehen wir eben und das ist...
Belastend.
Okay, dann hätten wir eine...
Was anderes Belastendes?
Das ist wirklich, das ist halt so langer Zeit belastend. Hätte uns bloß jemand vor mehr als zehn Jahren gewarnt.
Hans-Georg Maaßen, Hans-Georg Maaßen, ehemaliger Chef des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz, des Inlandsgeheimdienstes der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Derjenige Geheimnis, den wir uns leisten, der gegen uns selber spionieren darf.
Diesem stand der vor.
Ich glaube, in den Posten gehoben von dem damaligen Bundesinnenminister Hans-Peter Friedrich. Auch so eine absolute, also der war schon mit Landwirtschaft überfordert.
Und der hatte den Maaßen dahingesetzt nach dem Aktenschredderskandal bei denen im Hause, wenn ich das jetzt noch richtig in die Reihe kriege.
Und nicht mehr haltbar war Maaßen ja dann im Kontext irgendwelcher Corona-Nazis, die
in Chemnitz irgendwie randaliert haben, wo er dann sagte, das wäre irgendwie alles mit rechten Dingen zugegangen.
Mit rechten Dingen.
Ja, und seitdem ist er voll in der Schiene, komisch und lässt seinen Gedanken freien
Was jetzt dazu geführt hat, dass er in einem Interview mit irgendeinem, also ich weiß,
ich habe die Seite mir nur kurz angeguckt, das war auf jeden Fall so ein Fringeblatt, wo wieder die Rede irgendwie nur noch von der links-grünen gleichgeschalten Presse ist oder so. Da hat er in einem Interview davon fabuliert, es herrsche ein, wie war das Vernichtungsrassismus,
gegen Weiße in der links-grünen Ideologie oder so.
Wie bitte?
Also wirklich völlig absurd. Das wurde ein Tag später oder so.
Okay, das ist an mir vorbei gegangen, aber er ist ja auch gleichzeitig, glaube ich, zum Vorsitzenden der Werteunion gewählt worden, nicht?
Also der ist ja wirklich durch. Der ist ja wirklich so vollkommen abgebogen.
Will man meinen.
Jetzt gibt es natürlich Streit darüber, wann ist der Typ abgebogen?
Meine These ist ja, ganz, ganz früh ist der schon abgebogen.
Andere haben irgendwie so die Vorstellung, der hätte sich jetzt erst seit Kurzem zu einem völlig durchgeknallten entwickelt. So primär die CDU und auch die Junge Union, die nun auch im Ergebnis dieses Interviews, in dem er dann noch...
Ich will das jetzt gar nicht zitieren, ich hatte gerade noch überlegt, ob ich das als Quelle raussuche, aber solche Seiten verlinke ich nicht.
Irgendso ein, also wirklich wilden Shit und es ist auch nicht das erste Mal, dass der wilden Shit redet. Jetzt hat das CDU-Präsidium entschieden, dass sie ihn auffordern auszutreten aus der CDU.
Und wenn er das nicht tut, werden sie ein Parteiausschlussverfahren einleiten.
Und die Junge Union hat auch gesagt, sie möchte den nicht mehr haben und sie finden sogar, wird jetzt sogar darüber diskutiert, dass diese Werteunion, was ja einfach, sag ich mal so der.
Wie soll man das sagen? Der AfD-Förderverein in der CDU ist einfach Leute mit extrem rechten,
Positionen, die alles, was Fortschritt ist, für einen Verfall der Sitten halten, sich gegen die gendergerechte Sprache und Klimaschutz als die größten Probleme dieses Landes definiert haben und nun mit voller Inbunds bekämpfen.
Das ist ja so die Werteunion. Genau, zu deren Vorsitzender, wie du das gerade sagtest, der Hans-Georg Maaßen auch gewählt wurde.
Also die CDU hat jetzt, und das finde ich eigentlich das Spannende, die CDU hat jetzt mal so ein richtiges, ja so ein Sarrazin-Problem oder ein Wagenknecht-Problem oder ein Palmer-Problem.
Jede Partei hat ja so ihren durchgeknallten Würdenträger oder Würdenträgerin.
Und die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, die viele beschäftigt, wird der austreten, wird er
sich rauswerfen lassen? Die Antwort ist natürlich ganz klar nein. Der verfolgt ja eine Strategie der Normalisierung und das funktioniert für ihn einfach 1000 mal besser, wenn er in der CDU ist.
Solange er quasi seine, also er möchte ja, dass er nicht den extrem rechten Pol besetzt,
sondern dass die gesamte Gesellschaft sich in seinem Sinne entwickelt.
Dafür hat er mit der CDU natürlich einen sehr langen Hebel. Insofern wird er das genauso spielen wie die ganzen anderen Leute mit ihren parteischädigenden,
Verhaltensweisen, die diese mächtige Vereinigung der Partei natürlich für sich beanspruchen wollen, die ihre Sonderposition da drin genießen können.
De facto ist das einfach irgendein armer Typ, der ohne irgendwie nennenswertes Bundestagsmandat oder sonst was.
Aber jetzt hat er da irgendwie seinen Club innerhalb der CDU gegründet, ist einer der gefährlichsten oder der Unfriedenstifter in dieser Partei und kriegt damit sehr viel
Aufmerksamkeit, die er ja verlieren würde, wenn er jetzt morgen in der Zeitung steht.
Hans-Georg Maaßen beugt sich dem Wunsch von... Wie heißt noch mal der kleine Pascha da?
Wie heißt noch mal der CDU-Pascha?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hatte jetzt gesagt, ah okay.
Merz, Merz ist der so. hat beugt sich dem.
Ich musste direkt an Laschet denken, aber der hat nichts zu tun.
Aber der ist klein auf jeden Fall.
Maaßen beugt sich dem Wunsch von März und geht nach drüben in die AfD.
Das wäre dann ein großer Erfolg für die AfD, aber eine große Niederlage für Maaßen. Insofern wird er sich jetzt freuen, die nächsten Jahre mit dem Ausschlussverfahren aus der CDU,
ungefähr so viel Aufmerksamkeit wie Tilo Sarrazin über Jahre zu erhalten.
Und das ist alles ganz, ganz bedauerlich. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Wir wussten von Anfang an, dass der Typ gefährlich ist und sehr, sehr menschenverachtende Ansichten hegt. Und ich habe sie heute noch mal ein bisschen rausgesucht.
Der war das, der damals noch im Innenministerium, einfach als irgend so ein zweite Reihe Vöglein, ein Rechtsgutachten geschrieben hat zum Fall Murat Kurnas. Murat Kurnas war ein,
Deutscher, der auf einer Reise eingesackt wurde und in Guantanamo gelandet ist,
in Guantanamo Bay. Und dann war irgendwie Thema, dass er da vielleicht nicht zu Recht, also zu Recht sitzt niemand in Guantanamo Bay, weil das ja nicht.
Sagen wir mal, den rechtlichen Ansprüchen und auch den völkerrechtlichen Ansprüchen,
genügt dieser Ort, aber zumindest haben die ja Ideen, wen sie da festhalten wollen und wen nicht und diese Beschreibung, wofür man Guantanamo Bay
benutzen wollte, die traf so auf dem Rottkurnas nicht unbedingt zu. So, jetzt war die Frage, ist die Bundesrepublik Deutschland für den
verantwortlich, soll die sich den ausliefern lassen oder nach Hause bringen lassen, um den aus diesem Folterknast rauszuholen. Und da hat der Maaßen einen
Gutachten geschrieben, in dem er argumentierte, der sei jetzt schließlich länger als sechs Monate außer Landes und hätte keinen gültigen Pass mehr. Und damit hätte er seine Rechte verwirkt.
Sein Aufenthaltsrecht oder irgendwas. Und deswegen sollte die Bundesrepublik Deutschland sich den jetzt nicht mehr zurückholen, weil dann hätte er jetzt verwirkt, seine Staatsbürgerrechte. So hat
der Typ schon vor mehr als zehn Jahren, ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, wann das war, 2001 oder 2007 oder so diese Kurnas-Geschichte, so hat er damals schon argumentiert und jetzt tun auf einmal alle
ganz überrascht, dass das dermaßen ein völlig durchgeknallter Rechtsextrem-Rechter ist. Und das
finde ich erstaunlich, dass das mit dem so enden würde. Das war über lange Zeit vorhersehbar, Und ich glaube, das habe ich auch, als er dann endlich seinen Posten da verloren hatte,
auch hier schon so prognostiziert, dass er diese Entwicklung nehmen würde.
Und das ist alles ganz, ganz, ganz fürchterlich, wenn ich das mal ehrlich sagen darf.
Ja, das ist belastend. Aber wir haben ja auch irgendwie so ein paar andere Sachen,
die wir jetzt noch nachträglich rechtskräftig machen. Diese Behörde hat, glaube ich, aber nichts mit Maßen zu tun. Tatsächlich hat die Thomas de Maizière, seinerzeit Inminister,
2017 gegründet. Und ich weiß noch, dass am Anfang unheimlich viele Witze darüber gemacht wurden, dass sie kein Personal finden. Ich habe jetzt mal nachgeguckt. Also sie haben tatsächlich 300 von
346 Stellen derzeit besetzt. Also es wird langsam. Hat jetzt auch nur sechs Jahre gedauert, aber anscheinend finden sie Leute bzw. wahrscheinlich sind das die ganzen dualen Studenten, die sie irgendwie durch diesen Behördengame da durchschleusen oder so. Es geht um die
ZITES, um jetzt noch mal den Übergang zu finden für die Menschen, die das noch
nicht erraten haben.
Genau.
Die Situation mit der ZITES war ja so, die wurde einfach gegründet, ohne dass es ein,
Gesetz gibt, das ihre Zuständigkeiten und Aufgaben regelt. Und im Koalitionsvertrag stand der Ampel dann drin, yo voll geil, diese illegale Behörde,
eigentlich eine illegale Behörde. Die müssen wir jetzt nachträglich legalisieren. Was ich schon ein bisschen enttäuschend finde, wenn dir deine Vorgängerregierung eine dysfunktionale,
illegale Behörde überlässt, dass dir nichts besseres einfällt als zu sagen, dann müssen wir die jetzt halt mal legalisieren und die Versäumnisse der Vorgängerregierung, in diesem Fall ja CDU.
Aufarbeiten. Jetzt kommt aber heraus, bei der Gelegenheit wollen sie nicht nur das, was sie im Moment macht, legalisieren, sondern sie möchten gleichzeitig die Aufgaben,
die die CITES hat, erweitern. Und zwar die klassischen Themenbereiche sind Telekommunikationsüberwachung, Kryptoanalyse, Forensik und Big Data Analyse.
Das soll die CITES ja für Polizei und Geheimdienste gleichermaßen quasi als interne Dienstleisterin
durchführen. Und außerdem jetzt kommt hinzu, IT-Dienste wie Hosting für Polizei und Geheimdienste bereitstellen und betreiben.
Also kriegt sie sogar noch ein paar Aufgaben mehr. Jetzt ist Hosting erstmal nicht so viel. Allerdings, wenn die jetzt eventuell für alle Polizeien und Geheimdienste alles Mögliche,
hosten, dann kann da natürlich schon eine ganze Menge zusammenkommen, was da an weiteren,
Kompetenzen, Budget und Personal für notwendig ist.
Ja, und was vor allen Dingen interessant ist, finde ich, dass sie ja jetzt auch primär,
eher technische Tools bereitstellen soll und in Zukunft soll sie auch mehr Überwachungsfunktion
übernehmen, also wirklich aktiv Überwachungsmaßnahmen durchführen. Und derzeit ist zum Beispiel der BND noch nicht im Kundenkatalog der CITES.
Da steht jetzt auch die Frage im Raum, ob der nicht auch vielleicht noch dazukommen soll. Es ist so ein bisschen so, als wenn sie die Wunderlampe für alle Polizei- und Geheimdienste ist und die sich dann immer was wünschen können und die spuckt das dann so ein bisschen für die aus.
Und damit sie Überwachungsfunktionen anwenden kann, braucht sie eine spezifische Rechtsgrundlage
für die Verarbeitung personenbezogener Daten. Klar, kannst du ja nicht...
Aber das Lustige ist, derzeit stehen da nur so die DSGVO-Standards drin in diesem Vorschlag,
so eine richtige Kontrolle durch den Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten oder so, die ist noch nicht vorgesehen.
Das wäre ja noch schöner, wenn da auf einmal jemand die Überwacher überwacht. Schön ist, was nicht drin steht in diesem Eckpunktepapier, was jetzt hier, ich glaube,
von André Meister auf Netzwerktek.org veröffentlicht wurde. Was nicht drin steht, ist, dass sie Sicherheitslücken dem BSI melden soll, damit sie geschlossen werden. Die Ampel hat ja in
ihrem Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben, dass sie keine Sicherheitslücken ankaufen, offen halten,
sondern jeweils schnellstmöglich schließen wollen. Aber Nancy Feser sieht das ja anders Und entsprechend steht es jetzt auch nicht in dem Eckpunkt der Papier zur nachträglichen,
Legalisierung der ZITES. Das ist schon...
Ein hartes Brett, würde ich sagen. Ja, enttäuschend. Und vor allen Dingen ist es ja auch irgendwie so,
die ZITES arbeitet im Geheimen und da sind ja auch schon so die einen oder anderen Sachen zutage gekommen,
dass die dann auch gerne einfach sich mit, ich sag mal, Pegasus und Co. beschäftigen und da auch Verträge aushandeln etc. Also das ist echt.
Und man merkt hier wieder den langen Atem von André bei Netzpolitik.org,
denn 2021 im Juni, also vor ungefähr anderthalb Jahren, haben sie Klage gegen die ZITES eingereicht, um ein Dokument zu bekommen,
weil irgendein Juraprofessor, den ein Rechtsgutachten zu ihrer Aufgabenerfüllung verfasst hat.
Und das wollten sie aber nicht rausrücken, was natürlich ein bisschen vermutlich, ja, also man könnte sich vorstellen, dass dieses Rechtsgutachten von ähnlicher Qualität ist
wie Maassens Gutachten, warum man Murat Kurnas in Guantánamo verdorren lassen soll.
Oder auch so wunderschöne Ideen wie die Funktionsträgertheorie und die Weltraumtheorie, mit denen es sich ja auch schon irgendwie an Grundrechten und Sonstigen vorbeigeschubbelt wurde.
Insofern, ich glaube, das wird nochmal spannend, dieses wunderschöne Rechtsgutachten zu lesen. Aber es wird, wenn die ZITES jetzt legalisiert wird,
dann hat dieses Dokument im Zweifelsfall nur noch historischen Charakter. Aber es ist schon wirklich...
Also wenn man sowas von anderen Ländern erzählen würde, dass sie irgendwie so, ja die haben so eine Überwachungsbehörde ohne rechtliche Grundlage, dann würdest du denken, boah,
was ist denn da los? Aber irgendwie so in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat man sich da auch inzwischen irgendwie Schon so ein bisschen dran gewöhnt, oder?
Ja, und ich finde es vor allem krass, nach den ganzen Geschichten, die wir, Themen, die wir schon zu Staatsthorianern hatten, aber auch nach dieser ganzen Pegasus-Geschichte,
dass es, dass sie es trotzdem noch schaffen, die dann zu legalisieren und nicht zu sagen, jo, wir haben aus den letzten fünf Jahren gelernt und denken jetzt darüber nach, so einen Quatsch zurückzuziehen,
sondern sie legalisieren das dann nochmal hinterher.
Also das ist auch so nichts gelernt, keine Konsequenzen abgeleitet und irgendwie nur scharf auf Überwachungskompetenzen sein.
Ja, das ist eine… schwierig.
Es ist immer das Gleiche und man sucht ja auch immer… weißt du, wenn du dann mal jemanden hast, der oder die so die politische Perspektive darauf hat und vielleicht auch mal ein gewisses Augenmaß hat, dann ist die auf einmal in der zweiten Reihe bei einer,
Partei, die dann auf einmal an der Regierung ist und hat auf einmal andere Perspektiven oder andere Leute, denen sie nach dem Mund reden muss.
Aber dass man so richtig jemand sagt, so ne, das machen wir nicht, das passiert nicht.
Es gibt immer so einen Race to the Bottom in diesen Bereichen, was sich ja auch jetzt hier im PEGA Ausschuss zeigt. Verfolgst du den so ein bisschen?
Ja, also ich verfolge den am Rande und bekomme dann immer mit, wie Menschen sich sehr stark
darüber aufregen, weil ich das Gefühl habe, den haben sie so aufgesetzt, aber so richtig
viel mediale Aufmerksamkeit dafür, wie groß dieses Thema zwischenzeitlich war, bekommt der eigentlich nicht mehr.
Und der wurde ja jetzt auch bis zum Sommer verlängert, das heißt, die Tagen in diesem Ausschuss ja auch noch ein bisschen länger.
Und ja, das ist irgendwie, das was wir jetzt gerade zu dem ganzen Ziel des Themas gesagt haben, spiegelt eigentlich das wieder, was die jetzt auch gesagt haben in ihrem ersten
Entwurf, dass es sowohl fehlende Kooperation zur Aufklärung gibt, als auch keine Eigeninitiative für Aufklärung und Bekämpfung von solchen Problematiken.
Das ist wirklich eins zu eins, was wir mit der ZITES auch sehen.
Ja, ich muss tatsächlich sagen, ich gucke mir diese Pegaausschussgeschichten immer so,
... ich bin ehrlich, ich überflieg das so ein bisschen und denke mir immer so, ja, scheiße, scheiße, scheiße.
Aber es ist ja gewissermaßen auch... jetzt sage ich was, was man eigentlich nicht sagen sollte, da kommt jetzt nichts raus, was man nicht vorher schon gewusst hätte.
Aber das Schlimme ist, das haben wir vielleicht gewusst als kleine Community, die sich seit vielen Jahren damit auseinandersetzt, die seit vielen Jahren weiß, wer NSO ist, wer Finnfischer ist, was die anderen Akteure auf diesem Markt sind und was da alles so los ist.
Aber auf der EU-Ebene, wo jetzt irgendwie die Dinger gegeneinander gegen politische in Spanien und was da nicht alles gemacht wird mit diesen Zeug.
Das ist gewissermaßen, habe ich den Eindruck, bei diesem PEGA Ausschuss sind erstens ohnehin so ein Snowden-Effekt und zweitens dann auch noch mal im Schatten des Snowden-Effekts,
was das ganze Thema so komplett in Richtung Ferner-Liefen katapultiert. Und wenn du Pech hast, wurde das dann jetzt eben einmal auf EU-Ebene diskutiert, hatten
mal ja Untersuchungsausschuss zu und jetzt gib ihm. Oder weißt du durch deine Gespräche
in Brüssel und sonstigen Gefilden, dass sich daraus irgendeine Form von Konsequenz
und deutet, die dann noch kommen könnte.
Was heißt Konsequenz? Ich denke, dieser Ausschuss wird jetzt halt seine Empfehlung rausgeben
und seine Forderung, aber man sieht ja schon, dass die Kooperation einfach nicht da ist,
und jetzt so von der Wirkmacht auf PolitikerInnen. Also ich glaube, es ist schon eine Sensibilisierung da. Ich habe aber immer das Gefühl, dass das so ein bisschen getrennt voneinander betrachtet,
Also wenn wir jetzt über Pegasus reden und Überwachung von Journalisten und so, dann,
ist das alles total schlimm und das ist denen dann auch alles total klar.
Aber wenn wir dann zum Beispiel jetzt über Chatkontrolle reden, dann ist das alles auf einmal gar kein Thema mehr.
Und das ist so ein bisschen so eine, also die schaffen es nicht, das auch zusammen, also die schaffen nicht die Konsequenz dazu zu ziehen und auch das zusammenzubringen, dass die sich jetzt mit jedem Überwachungsgesetz sozusagen, was sie mehr machen,
sie sich weiter in dieses Bein schießen.
Also ich glaube, es führt zu einer gewissen Sensibilisierung,
Aber das zusammen zu betrachten fehlt halt einfach.
Jetzt wehren sich natürlich noch ein paar Leute dagegen.
Reporter ohne Grenzen hat, glaube ich, zwei Sachen.
Die haben eine Beschwerde gegen den BND laufen am europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte.
Und die haben aber jetzt auch irgendwie eine Verhandlung vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig, Wo es um den Ausschluss von, also quasi das Sicherstellen, dass Journalistinnen und Journalisten nicht betroffen sein können.
Das war glaube ich das Primärthema von RSF, oder?
Genau, also die haben halt eine Verfassungsbeschwerde eingelegt. Und zwar gegen, das ist auch eine Reform, über die du dich schon sehr aufgeregt hast,
die 2021 beschlossene Reform des Verfassungsschutzes, das Quellen-TKÜ erlaubt hat. Also um dieses Thema geht es. Ja, bitte. Du hast dich heute noch nicht so viel aufgeregt.
Soll ich mich nochmal aufregen? Ne, ich setze kurz einen aus. Ja.
Ja. Okay, dann nicht. Genau und es geht halt darum, dass Reporter ohne Grenzen befürchtet, dass sie gegebenenfalls auch vom BND überwacht werden könnten, wenn sie mit vertraulichen
Quellen im Ausland kommunizieren. Das ist so ein bisschen die Basis von dieser Verfassungsbeschwerde und diese Anhörung hat am 25.01., also irgendwie vor sechs Tagen, stattgefunden. Und jetzt,
Es ist spannend, wie es weitergeht, weil die haben ja schon mal verloren.
Ich meine, das war 2017, ich kriege das jetzt nicht mehr so genau zusammen.
Also sie haben schon mal eine ähnliche Verfassungsbeschwerde eingelegt und das Ding verloren.
Okay, also da bleiben wir dran und schauen uns mal an.
Es gibt außerdem, wenn wir jetzt hier gerade schon bei der ganz großen Überwachung sind, eine Verfassungsbeschwerde der GFF gegen Palantir.
Genau, also nicht direkt gegen Palantir, sondern es geht halt um die automatisierte Datenanalyse
durch Strafverfolgungsbehörden und insbesondere um das Polizeigesetz in Hamburg und Bayern, weil dieses Polizeigesetz nämlich so eine ganz drastische Lücke gelassen hat.
In Hamburg ist das § 49, der es halt erlaubt automatisiert Daten zu verarbeiten.
Und vielleicht möchtest du noch mal kurz sagen, was Palantir eigentlich macht. Da wird es nämlich dann interessant. Das Spielzeug von Peter Thiel.
Palantir ist, was machen die?
Also erstmal glaube ich, die machen, genau, Peter Thiel's Überwachungs-Startup, die Big Data-Analysen machen in vielen unterschiedlichen Bereichen,
aber insbesondere als Wirkungsbereich so Geheimdienste, polizeiliche Massenüberwachung.
Big Data auf deviantes Verhalten oder so, bauen und tatsächlich spezifisch so Polizei und sowas als Zielgruppe haben. Und ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt,
glaube ich, dass die ein bisschen übertreiben mit dem, was sie können, aber,
ziemlich üble. Also das ganze Ding ist ziemlich übel. Der Palantir ist doch irgendwie so ein Stein aus Herr der Ringe?
Das ist... ist das nicht das Auge?
Nein, nein, nein. Es gibt mehrere. Das Auge ist sauron.
Also ja, das Auge ist aber okay, weil... Jetzt muss ich mich outen. Ich hab immer nur die Filme geguckt und nie die Bücher gelesen. Wahrscheinlich fehlt mir dieser Kontext.
Also, ein Palantir ist, glaube ich, ein Stein. Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob mehr Leute uns das jetzt erklären als wir erklärt haben.
Vielleicht musst du dann auch wieder so viele neue Kommentare freischalten, weil wir die Herder Ring in Nerds noch nicht getriggert haben.
Also, was ist ein Palant hier?
Also es sind sehende Steine, die in die Ferne blicken können. Also über die Steine waren vollkommen glatte Kugeln von schwarzem massiven Glas und da.
Okay.
Kannst du irgendwie mit...
Ah, das ist diese Kugel, weißt du, die auch Gandalf bei sich hat zwischenzeitlich.
Ja, und Aragon hat den auch mal.
Ich erinnere mich.
Genau, das ist ein Palantir. Was die so anbieten ist, Palantir entwickelt hochperformante Softwareplattformen, die das,
als zentrale Betriebssystem für Resiliente und Datengestützte, Organisationen des 21. Jahrhunderts dienen.
Foundry, das Betriebssystem für moderne Unternehmen. Gotham, das Betriebssystem für moderne Sicherheitsbehörden. Also die haben auf jeden Fall ganz schön viel Fernsehen gesehen.
Das gibt es dann auch nur in schwarz-weiß, oder? Also das Gotham-Betriebssystem.
Gotham ist ja, denke ich mal, so Batman entlehnt. Apollo ist das Betriebssystem von Continuous Delivery.
Also das Interessante ist, es gibt ja noch ein paar mehr von diesen Dingern auf dem Markt. gibt ja nicht nur Palantir leider. Und ich glaube, das ist auch was, was man immer vergisst. Und dieser Trend, dass Polizisten oder Polizisten, genau, die Polizisten kaufen die eine,
aber dass die Polizei sich diese Ressourcen einkauft, ist tatsächlich ein sehr beunruhigender aus meiner Sicht. Aber du wolltest noch erzählen, was da noch auf dem Datenblatt steht.
Sie haben irgendwo hier so ein kleines Ding.
Datenschutz und Datenethik gehören zu unseren Grundversprechen und unserer Unternehmensphilosophie.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt. Was habt ihr denn da?
Wir verpflichten uns ethischen Grundprinzipien. Wir investieren in Funktionalitäten, die eine verantwortungsvolle Verarbeitung von Daten erleichtern.
Erleichtern. Das ist, damit die niemand verklagen kann.
Also Palantir ist, glaube ich, auf jeden Fall eines von den Unternehmen, die jetzt nicht großartig Don't Be Evil als Message hätten und auch sicherlich nicht,
als Teil ihrer PR oder Corporate Identity. Aber kommen wir zurück. Da gab es also jetzt eine Verfassungsbeschwerde der GFF gegen automatische Datenanalyse bei der Polizei.
Habt ihr das richtig verstanden?
Und die wurde angenommen und wurde verhandelt.
Genau, die wurde verhandelt.
Constanze war auch als technische Sachverständige vor Ort.
Und da warten wir jetzt sozusagen auf das Urteil. Es wird aber ein Urteil geben, es wird aber nicht der große Bahnbruch sein,
dass wir jetzt einen Grundsatzurteil zu vor allen Dingen auch KI-gestützten Systemen haben.
Es wird sich wirklich nur auf diese automatisierte Datenverarbeitung beziehen. Und ja, da ist die Richterin leider nicht ganz so uns entgegenkommend gewesen.
Okay, also das heißt, da wird es nicht irgendein dickes Fundamental-Urteil geben, aber immerhin
setzen sich jetzt mal die Gerichte damit auseinander, was es denn bedeutet. Alle staunen gerade über Chat-GPT und langsam kommt ihnen vielleicht irgendwann mal ins Bild, was das bedeutet, wenn eine solche Technologie unsere Überwachung für uns erledigt.
Okay, und dann hast du noch eine Übersicht über die globale Verwendung von Spyware gefunden, was ich tatsächlich sehr spannend finde, weil ich längst den Überblick verloren habe in dem Bereich.
Ja, fand ich irgendwie total spannend, dass es mir irgendwie so über den Weg gelaufen
und das bezieht sich tatsächlich auf die Verwendung, den Kauf und die Herstellung im
Zeitraum von 2011 bis 2022 und ist eine Auswertung basiert auf ganz, ganz vielen Datenpunkten, also auch zum Beispiel Daten vom Citizen Lab, aber auch von anderen Forschungseinrichtungen, die sich mit diesen Themen beschäftigen.
Vielleicht kommen, Fynn Fischer wird bestimmt auch drin vorkommen.
Fand ich aber interessant, das mal so auf einem Haufen zu haben und das mal benennen zu können.
Vielleicht baut noch jemand so eine interaktive Karte aus den Datenpunkten.
Das wäre doch mal eine interessante Sache.
Also diese Darreichungsform als Excel-Sheet kann ich jetzt nur Punkte geben dafür, dass sie wenigstens keine Leerzeichen im Dateinamen haben, aber ansonsten kann ich hier wirklich wenig Punkte geben für die Form der Aufbereitung.
Also das kann man, da hast du recht, da kann man auf jeden Fall noch was draus machen. Vielleicht mal als CSV exportieren und versuchen.
Aber ja, okay, dann sind wir wenigstens, also es sind im Prinzip welche Unternehmen es so gibt. Und, boah Kinder, ihr müsst doch mal wenigstens hier Filter oben an den, okay also,
Junge, Junge, Junge, die müssen wir bei mir in die Einführungstrainings irgendwie excel, Excel für den ersten Tag, wo du arbeitest. Gucken wir mal, Finnfischer. Oh, Finnfischer,
ganz schön viel. Ja, da kannst du, also da haben sie relativ viel zu, auf jeden Fall mehr als ich,
gedacht hätte. Und auch eine ganze Anzahl Länder, auch mehr als ich dachte, in denen es jetzt die
die in den das eingesetzt wurde. Zum Beispiel bin ich mir nicht sicher, also ich glaube Serbien hätte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt auf dem Schirm gehabt. Venezuela weiß ich nicht genau.
Kasachstan hätte ich jetzt auch nicht spontan gewusst. Okay, das war ganz gute Sammlung, aber letztendlich haben sie einfach nur alles, wo es mindestens zwei Quellen gibt.
Okay, aber immerhin, das ist schon mal ein ganz guter Ansatz, der sich so für die Recherche eignet.
Ist da Palantir jetzt dabei?
Ne, Palantir nicht, weil Palantir ja nur Big Data ist und nicht unbedingt Überwachungs. Na ja, okay, alles klar.
Naja, wahrscheinlich würden.
Sehr schönes Spreadsheet. Ich lade die mal demnächst ein, um einen kleinen Excel-Kurs mit mir zu machen.
Beim nächsten Thema sind die schwedische Ratspräsidentschaft hat sich mal im Einführungskurs für Massenüberwachung versucht.
Also, ich mache mal wieder den Einführungskurs EU-Politik für Anfängerinnen.
Jetzt musst du erstmal wieder, es tut mir leid, aber ich muss erstmal nochmal erklären, Wer ist denn die schwedische Ratspräsidentschaft?
Also, es ist so, dass wir ja den Rat haben, in dem unsere ganzen Mitgliedsländer und die Fachabteilung vertreten sind.
Ich nehme die Chatkontrolle mal als Beispiel.
Arbeitet die Strafverfolgungsratsarbeitsgruppe für den Rat an dem Thema.
Der Rat muss natürlich auch irgendwie einen Vorsitz haben. Deswegen gibt es eine Ratspräsidentschaft, die alle sechs Monate rotiert.
Und das ist jetzt aktuell seit dem 1. Januar Schweden, davor war es Tschechien, ab dem Sommer
ist es dann Spanien. Und das ist eigentlich ein mehr administratives Amt als ein Amt, das super stark ins Gewicht
fällt.
Aber dadurch, dass sie natürlich Pläne mit entwickeln und immer den Vorsitz bei den entsprechenden Sitzung haben und so weiter und so fort, haben sie natürlich irgendwie
eine gewisse Möglichkeit Schwerpunkte zu setzen.
Und das haben die Schweden jetzt auch getan und haben in der letzten Woche zur informellen,
Sitzung der Justiz- und Innenministerin in Stockholm ein Papier herausgegeben.
Was wirklich, also es fühlt sich so an, als wenn Ilver Johansson das geschrieben hat.
Wahrscheinlich hat Ilver Johansson es auch geschrieben, dass es die EU-Kommissarin, die die Chatkontrolle auf den Weg gebracht hat.
Und ja, was soll ich sagen?
Also es ist wirklich, also ja, Überwacher sind begeistert. Also von Geheimdienste haben ein echtes Problem damit, dass es überhaupt Verschlüsselungen,
gibt, weil sie so überhaupt gar nicht mehr richtig ermitteln können.
Und deswegen musste man Methoden schaffen, die Verschlüsselung untergräbt bis hin zu,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Austausch von Evidenz und Daten über Grenzen hinaus und so weiter
und so fort.
Es ist einfach wirklich alles dabei und auch so ein bisschen so dieses, man müsste Privatsphäre
und die Ziele der Strafverfolgungsbehörden miteinander vereinbaren. der Wunsch.
Ja, ich finde, es malt so ein bisschen das Bild, was wir gerade irgendwie überall sehen,
noch mal sehr direkt auf. Ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst, aber ich fand es irgendwie sehr deprimierend,
dass sie jetzt mit sowas um die Ecke kommen.
Aber du hast gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht, das ist quasi die inhaltliche Schwerpunktsetzung,
wo sie sagen, damit möchten wir uns dann jetzt auseinandersetzen in der Zeit, vor allem ausredend Schweden.
Eigentlich, ja, ist auch schon etwas länger her, dass die hoch auf der Liste der besonderen Länder waren.
Aber was ist bei denen innenpolitisch los, dass sie jetzt ausgerechnet sich dieses Thema aussuchen?
Weil du hast jetzt, ok, dann hast du jetzt mal sechs Monate den Vorsitz im Rat der EU. Wie du schon sagst, eher administrativ, aber das kleine bisschen, was du hast, willst du dann irgendwie für deinen Kampf gegen die Verschlüsselung aufwenden.
Wie kommt's?
Ich kann es dir gar nicht so genau sagen.
Also was man halt immer sagen muss, und ich glaube, das kann man sich manchmal als gerade
deutsche Person nicht so vorstellen, weil wir ja sehr stark sensibilisiert sind für so Datenhörungsfragen, ist, dass viele Menschen in Skandinavien insbesondere ein ganz anderes Verhältnis zur Privatsphäre haben.
Und die haben so ein Urvertrauen in den Staat und finden deswegen einige Sachen einfach total in Ordnung. Und ich glaube, das ist das eine. Und ich glaube, das andere ist wirklich,
dass du hier einfach einen extrem starken Einschlag von der Elva Johannsen hast, die Kommentarin auch für Innenpolitik ist, die einfach, dass sich sozusagen, ja, also wie,
alle deutschen Innenministerinnen halt auch irgendwie, weißt du so, die kommen dann in
dieses Field und dann wollen sie sich damit einen Namen machen und dann wird halt die
Erwachungskanone rausgeholt. Also anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
Und ja.
Ideas what it is.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Okay, aber geht auch wieder vorbei, sagste. Sechs Monate. Wer kommt danach?
Spanien meine ich. Also Spanien, Belgien müsste.
Also wenn man ganz runter scrollt bei dem Link in den Show notes zu der Erklärung,
Du kannst bis 2030 gucken, wie die Rastpräsidentschaften wechseln.
Oh ja, stimmt. Spanien, Belgien, Ungarn, Polen.
Als nächstes ist Spanien und Belgien, Ungarn, Polen.
Also es wird nicht unbedingt besser.
Dänemark, Zypern, Irland, Litauen, Griechenland, Italien, Lettland, Luxemburg, Niederland, Slowakei, Malt. Okay, ja, also super. Das Problem ist, wenn man sich die Liste so
anschaut, inzwischen traust du jedem Land was ordentliches zu, was übeles zu. Also an oberster Stelle Deutschland. Juli bis Dezember 2020. Ja, ja, ist klar, war auch nicht gut.
Ne, natürlich nicht. Und ich meine, Belgien hat ein super krasses Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgesetz.
Die Spanier sind auch nicht unbedingt so krass sensibilisiert für diese Themen, haben ja auch fröhlich Menschen überwacht mit Pegasus. Also es wird, also es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt,
gemütlich. Also es sind jetzt auch nicht die besten fünf, top fünf Ratspräsidentschaften,
die ich mir zusammenstellen würde, wenn ich mir Gedanken über diese ganze Chat-Kontrollen-Gesetzgebung,
machen muss.
Da kommen wir gleich nochmal zu.
Hier geht es ja jetzt im Prinzip um die Steigerung der Überwachungsmöglichkeiten von EU-Bürgerinnen und Bürgern.
Aber die haben sich doch bestimmt auch ein paar Gedanken darüber gemacht, was wir jetzt außerhalb der EU mit Nicht-EU-Bürgerinnen und Bürgern machen können, oder? Also da wird es doch irgendwie noch was geben, wo sie sagen, da wo wir keine aktuellen rechtlichen Einschränkungen haben,
Da müssen wir auch noch welche abbauen.
Oder was haben Sie sich da so gedacht?
Naja, es ist eher so ein bisschen anders. Sie haben einfach keine rechtlichen Einschränkungen.
Was machen Sie da?
Also es geht jetzt halt um die Behandlung von geflüchteten Personen an den Außengrenzen,
und alles, worum wir hier gerade kämpfen. Zum Beispiel im AI Act, wo es ganz klar darum geht, dass AI-basierte Systeme zum Beispiel nicht für irgendwelche Social Scoring-Sachen,
benutzt werden oder irgendwie um Risk Assessment für Kriminelle zu machen. Das wird alles so im AI geregelt und das ist auch ein unheimlicher Aufreger, sage ich mal so, in der Zivilgesellschaft.
Aber wenn wir mal an unsere Außengrenzen gucken, dann läuft da halt schon eine ganze Menge davon. Also es werden Risk Assessments mit Hilfe von AI von Geflüchteten gemacht,
die natürlich, also diese AI ist natürlich mit den Daten, die an den U-Ausgrenzen gesammelt wurden, trainiert,
also hatten einen entsprechenden Bias.
Es werden Biometriedaten gesammelt. Es gibt eine ganz große Datenbank, die heißt EuroDAC.
Da sammeln sie die ganzen Fingerabdrücke von geflüchteten Personen.
Und die ist halt über die ganze EU verknüpft, damit sie natürlich auch, wenn sie dann
irgendwo irgendjemanden finden in irgendeinem Mitgliedsland, den auch schön wieder an die
richtige Grenze zurückschicken können. Und das alles könnte man in dem AI Act regeln, machen sie aber nicht.
Frontex ist allen Menschen ein Begriff und das ist schon eine Vollkatastrophe, aber was
die da technologisch bringen, ist eine noch viel größere Vollkatastrophe.
Wir hatten ja eben dieses hässliche Spreadsheet.
Tatsächlich hat Statewatch eine sehr schöne Animation gemacht.
Den kannst du ja vielleicht gleich auch mal live öffnen und dich da durchklicken. Die wird dir Freude bringen.
Von allen Emigrations- und Polizeidatenbanken, die in Europa verknüpft sind miteinander.
Das ist ein komplizierter Knoten.
Verbinde alle Punkte mit allen Punkten.
Ja.
Genau, es ist genau so. Also wenn man sich das anguckt, dann ist es sehr verknüpft.
Man kann aber auf alle Einzelpunkte so draufklicken und dann erklärt er dir auch, was die Datenbank
eigentlich macht und was die da speichern. Und das ist ganz schön viel.
Okay, das war... Ja, das stimmt. Okay. The map.
Kannst du ja mal...
Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist noch schlimmer als die Cyber-Sicherheitsarchitektur von Deutschland.
Dann haben wir hier so etwas wie den Biometric Matching Service, der Templates von generierten.
Ja, nur wahrscheinlich funktioniert es besser, das ist wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen das Problem. Da haben sie also auch nichts davon gelernt, was Cantorkel und Snoopy und Starbuck vorgetragen.
Biometrischen Daten sammelt und speichert.
Haben. Die könnten wir öfter unsere Vorträge besuchen oder zumindest mal im Internet gucken. müssen sie die nicht. Okay, also da geht es auch munter weiter in die Dystopie.
Bist du mit dem Thema durch oder kommen wir noch hier noch mal kurz zu Frontex?
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Wir können ja nochmal zu Frontex kommen an dieser Stelle, weil ich finde, der Frag den
Staat hat da wirklich eine wunderbare Aktion gemacht.
Also das Headquarter von Frontex ist in Warschau. Wusste ich tatsächlich vorher auch nicht. Wusstest du, dass das ein Warschau ist?
Ich glaube ja, weil die da doch mal so eine Klage verloren haben, da sind Arne und seine Kollegin, wo ich jetzt gerade leider nicht weiß, welche Kollegin das genau war, da
um die 10.000 Euro, die sie verloren hatten, in Bar zu überreichen. Und da erinnere ich mich an das Video.
Und da waren sie, glaube ich, aber ich hätte jetzt auch nicht aus dem Kopf Warschau gesagt, aber ich wusste, wusste, dass es, ich hätte jetzt, also es war auf jeden Fall Richtung Osten und eine,
irgendwie kleinere schöne Stadt. Gucken wir mal, finde ich dieses Video noch? Hier, da ist es.
Da steht dann nicht die Name, steht wer das Foto gemacht hat, aber nicht der Name der Kollegin von Arne, die war doch da federführend. Steht überhaupt nicht, Arne steht gar nicht mit dabei.
Okay, finde ich raus, aber wir verlinken es mal. Aber okay, also ihr habt schon wieder eine neue Frontex-Aktion, ja?
Genau, sie haben nämlich sich den schönen Spruch, den es ja auch immer in der Prävention gab,
Gibt See something, say something genommen und komplett um das Frontex Headquarter,
riesengroße Plakate aufgehängt, die zu Whistleblowing-Aktionen bei Front-Hacks aufrufen.
Sehr schön. Okay, das dürfte nicht so schwer sein,
also dazu whistleblown. Es ist ja nicht so, als würden die da selten was Verbotenes tun. Das ist ja relativ häufig, dass so was jetzt auch zum Beispiel von unseren Freunden aus der zivilen Seenotrettung gezeigt wird, dass,
Frontex mal wieder was Illegales tut. Kleine Korrektur, die kleine Stadt, in die fragt den Staat gereist sind, war Brüssel. Sie haben versucht, insgesamt.
Ja, okay.
10.520,76 Euro persönlich in bar als Brüsseler Büro zu übergeben, das sich jetzt hier versehentlich für eine kleine europäische
Stadt Warschau, Brüssel, Hauptsache. Und es war auch nicht nur Arne. Auf dem ersten Bild waren,
sie zu zweit, aber es ist Arne mit eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs Kolleginnen. Und es steht,
trotzdem nicht unterm Bild, wer jetzt die Menschen sind, die da abgebildet sind. Auch bei Arne nicht, immerhin. Okay, also Whistleblowing bei Frontex finden wir gut, können wir unterstützen. Bluen können wir ohnehin unterstützen.
Ja, es gibt auch eine Whistleblowing Plattform für die Ölindustrie. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast.
Die ist auch von Fragtenstaat, meine ich. Aber das nur am Rande.
Okay, dann schauen wir mal, finden wir die auch noch? Finden wir die auch noch zur Verlinkung?
Bestimmt.
All the front-end documents... Packen wir gleich in die Show notes, müssen wir jetzt nicht die Zeit unserer Hörerinnen mit vergeuden,
Aber ich würde an dieser Stelle gerne noch mal ganz kurz auf einen kleinen Exkurs zur zivilen Seenotrettung machen.
Und zwar einmal haben wir ja vor ein paar Mal hier aufgerufen, für die Kabul-Luftbrücke zu spenden.
Wir hatten ja das Ziel, 1000 Euro zusammenzubekommen. Innerhalb von sechs Stunden hatten wir das dann erreicht.
Dann haben wir das Spendenziel immer weiter erhöht, bis ich es irgendwann auf 9500 Euro erhöht hatte.
Jetzt habe ich mal reingeschaut.
Wir sind jetzt bei 12.466,70 Euro.
Das ist der Stand, den die Logbuch-Netzpolitik Einhorn-Standarte an die Cabo Luftbrücke gespendet hat.
Nicht ohne Stolz kann ich betonen, dass wir von allen, die da eine solche Spendenaktion machen, diejenigen sind, die am meisten zusammen bekommen haben.
Da sind aber auch zum Beispiel sehr coole Leute, die einfach mal hier zum Beispiel Leas 35.
Da hat Lea ihren 35. gefeiert und hat daraus eine Spendenaktion gemacht und hat ihr Ziel mal eben ganz locker erreicht.
Oder die Restrealität hat mal gesagt, wir werfen mal ein Tausender zusammen und hat das auch geschafft. Insofern sind auch sehr viele, die aus viel kleineren,
viel kleineren Communities kommen, wie zum Beispiel einer Geburtstagsparty und hier gespendet haben. Das finde ich sehr schön und dafür noch
nochmals vielen Dank. Und außerdem ist ja gerade, da gibt es eine sehr spannende
Einlassung von Chez Hombi. Oh man, wie spricht man den Namen denn aus?
Weiß ich nicht, ich müsste ihn geschrieben sehen, damit ich dir das beantworten kann.
Sejan Binder. Ich habe leider, ja, aber er ist in Deutschland geboren und in Irland aufgewachsen.
Heißt es nicht einfach schon?
Also Sean Binder wahrscheinlich. Oder in Deutschland, weißte, geil. Aber die Iren machen ja gerne bei ihm noch so ein verwirrendes Akzent irgendwohin oder sowas. Sean Binder, sag ich jetzt. Und er hat,
ein sehr, das geht glaube ich so ein bisschen viral zurecht, seine Einlassung zum Gerichtstermin auf der griechischen Insel Lesbos, weil er sich der Menschenrettung engagiert hat. Er,
sagt etwas ganz einfach. Stell dir vor, es passiert ein Autounfall. Ein Mensch liegt am Straßenrand, er braucht Hilfe. Was würdest du zuerst checken? Den Puls oder den Pass?
Das ist alles, was dazu zu sagen ist zur organisierten zivilen Seenotrettung. Und das fand ich wirklich sehr eindrücklich, was er dort vorgetragen hat.
Zu seiner Verteidigung, die er jetzt da vortragen muss, steht potenziell auf dem Spiel eine,
Haftstrafe für ihn, weil er Menschenleben gerettet hat und eben zuerst den Puls geprüft hat und nicht den Pass.
Ja, das also auch noch mal kurz von mir als Einwurf und dann können wir endlich, wenn ihr wisst, wenn Khaleesi hier ist, kommen wir um ein Thema nicht drum herum.
Es ist auch weiterhin das wichtigste Thema des Jahres.
Ich bleibe dabei.
Und jetzt steht da, es könnte ganz schnell gehen, damit meinst du nicht, dass wir dieses Thema hier besprechen, sondern dass die...
Das habe ich ja schon mit Tim gemacht, der hat doch schon Striche geführt,
weil ich nicht über Chatkontrolle geredet habe.
Aber vorher kurzer Einschub, es geht tatsächlich bei dieser Plattform zum Meldung von, zum Whistleblown geht es nicht um die Ölindustrie, sondern um die Gaslobby.
Ich habe mich geirrt, also das nur als kurze Charakter. Und jetzt auf kürzestem Weg zurück zur Chatkontrolle. Die Chatkontrolle ist mein Leben. Und... ...
Sendungstipp.
... ...
... Also...
Und genau, deswegen bin ich daran interessiert, dass es jetzt ganz schnell geht und ich dann nach Urlaub machen kann. Nein, Spaß beiseite.
Eigentlich haben wir nicht so viel Interesse daran, dass es ganz schnell geht, weil wir wissen alle.
Lenus, was ist 2024?
Äh, Ratspräsidentschaft?
Das, was in Berlin jetzt auch endlich stattfinden darf, aber für die EU.
Was ist das für ein Thema?
Genau.
Also 2024 wird gewählt, also nicht in Berlin, sondern in der EU.
Was ist das für ein Thema? Das sieht ja alles gerade gar nicht so gut aus.
Und vielleicht legen Sie es mit den EU-Wahlen zusammen, dann ist es ein bisschen einfacher.
Aber dann geht wieder was schief. Das andere war mit den Bundestagswahlen gemeinsam.
Okay, was macht eigentlich Franziska Giffey, wenn sie nicht wiedergewählt wird?
Sie wird schon irgendwo unterkommen. Also wird sie wahrscheinlich eine Rolle mit anderem Schadenspotenzial in ähnlichem oder größerem Ausmaß suchen.
Das Innenministerium wird ja bald frei. Also, nochmal, Versuch, Chatkontrolle.
Soll ich wieder von vorne anfangen und nochmal EU-Gesetzgebungsprozess ganz kurz einmal
antisern, damit verständlich ist?
Ist ja auch total einfach, der ist ja sehr einfach erklärt.
Ja, findest du?
Nein, deswegen finde ich auch das klassische Fall von mal eben kurz an teasern. Nee, aber sag mal ganz kurz, die Phase ist schonmal wichtig, vor allem an welcher wir uns gerade befinden.
Dann erklär das doch mal!
Die hab ich das doch schon.
Genau, also ich glaube, das letzte Mal, als ich ausführlicher darüber berichtet habe,
waren wir an einer ähnlichen Stelle.
Wir sind jetzt ein bisschen weiter. Also die Ausschüsse wurden verteilt und der Stand der Dinge ist, dass der Liebeausschuss, das ist der Ausschuss für bürgerliche Freiheit, Justiz und Inneres, sozusagen den Lied bekommen
hat, also die Hauptverantwortung für das Pfeil. Und dass die anderen Ausschüsse, also einmal der IMKO, das ist der Ausschuss für den Binnenmarkt und Verbraucherschutz, und FEMM, das ist der,
Ausschuss für Frauenrechte und ich glaube sogar Kinder, so wie das halt leider immer ist, sozusagen nur eine Opinion haben. Das heißt, die geben dann ihre Meinung dazu ab,
aber das fällt nicht so stark ins Gewicht wie der federführende Ausschuss.
Und der Stand der Dinge ist nach wie vor, dass sowohl IMKO, also Innenausschuss, als,
auch FEM, also Frauenrechte, gesagt haben, na ja. Also IMKO hat halt gesagt, na ja, also die Rechtsgrundlage ist halt der Binnenmarkt,
wäre schon ganz gut, wenn wir dann auch ein bisschen mehr Mitbestimmungsrechte hätten,
wenn es um die Verhandlung dieses Reports geht. Und FEM hat gesagt, das ist ja auch ein Thema, was Gendergerechtigkeit betrifft, weil ein,
Hauptgrund, warum wir auch diese sexuellen Missbrauchsthemen haben, ist auch einfach,
Gendergerechtigkeit. Dementsprechend fordern die gerade noch Kompetenzen ein. Das kann man sich so vorstellen, wenn mehr als einer von diesen Ausschüssen Kompetenzen
hat, dann werden die Artikel auf die Ausschüsse je nach Themenbereich sozusagen aufgeteilt.
Also die kriegen dann irgendwie fünf Artikel, die besonders gut in ihren Themenbereich passen.
Und was diese Ausschlüsse dann machen, und das passiert sozusagen gerade, die schreiben einen sogenannten Report.
Aber was dieser Report am Ende des Tages ist, ist, dass sie ihre Änderungen zu dem Gesetz,
reingeben. Also sagen, der Artikel passt uns nicht, schreibt da mal das und das rein.
Das ist dieser Report. Und in dieser Phase sind wir gerade. Und der Report wird dann vorgestellt, dann können die ganzen Abgeordneten noch Änderungen dazu machen.
Und dann wird das in den Ausschüssen abgestimmt.
Und dann geht es danach ins Parlament.
Und das ist ja sozusagen das, was jetzt interessant für uns ist. Und es sieht jetzt halt so aus, als würden sie es auch versuchen, ein bisschen zu beschleunigen.
Das heißt, der Report kommt wahrscheinlich irgendwann im Frühjahr und im Herbst soll das auch schon abgestimmt werden und dann auch noch in diesem Jahr ins Parlament gehen.
Okay, das wäre wann ungefähr? Also in diesem Jahr?
Also im Herbst, also vermutlich irgendwann, ich schätze, also das kann man alles nicht
sagen, ne?
Also das ist halt so ein bisschen so, wie die schwedische Ratspräsidentschaft sich vornimmt, mehr Überwachung zu bekommen, nehmen sich dann bestimmte Ausschüsse vor, im Herbst,
ihre Sachen fertig zu haben und abzustimmen.
Ob das dann wirklich passiert, kann man nicht sagen, aber das ist sozusagen erstmal das,
was sie sich vorstellen.
Okay, wenn ich dich jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ist gewissermaßen eigentlich...
Also am besten wäre, wenn sie es gar nicht zur Entscheidung bringen. Das wäre das Beste.
Oder siehst du Chancen, dass man das, was die bis dahin, also dass man in diesem Zeitraum noch alles Schlechte aus dieser Idee heraus überzeugt bekommt.
Also du meinst einfach alles rauslöschen und nur die Überschrift abstimmen?
Nein, also ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen, wir haben das, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich
an Terec erinnerst, also da ging es um terroristischen Content online. Das haben wir ja auch so kurz vor so einer EU-Wahl übers Knie gebrochen mit ganz viel Moral Panic und irgendwie so.
Und ja, das ist jetzt irgendwie der gleiche Fall.
Und Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellung ist natürlich dann noch mehr ein Moral-Moral-Panic-Thema
als terroristischer Content. Das heißt, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand sich dahinstellen wird, also weder von den PolitikerInnen, also wer echt stark und echt wünschenswert, weil wie gesagt, die adressieren
ja, es ist total, also die Probleme, die sie in ihrem, in diesem Gesetz nennen und die
Sachen, womit sie die adressieren wollen, gehen halt komplett aneinander vorbei.
Also das ist ja wirklich echt fast schon komisch, wie schlecht es ist, aber es wird halt trotzdem
keiner sich hinstellen und sagen, nein, wir sind komplett dagegen.
Also weil das halt einfach ein viel zu schwieriges, sensibles Thema ist leider.
Also heißt das, wir haben jetzt nur noch wenige Monate Zeit, die Idee so wenig schlecht wie
möglich zu machen. Weil das zu verhindern, wird auf jeden Fall nicht passieren. Also das komplette Ding vom Tisch zu fegen wird nicht mehr passieren.
Also ich sage mal so, wir werden es natürlich versuchen, aber also die Position ist da glaube
ich sehr klar. Ich bin auch sehr gespannt, was die Bundesregierung jetzt macht. Also vor Weihnachten,
hatten wir ja mitbekommen, so Kommando zurück, unsere internen Abteilungen haben Mist gebaut,
wir müssen unsere Position noch mal neu machen. Und die erwarten wir jetzt auch irgendwie,
eigentlich dachten wir alle, dass die Ende Januar kommt. Jetzt ist der letzte Tag im Januar, es noch nichts passiert. Das ist auch total witzig, weil diese Arbeitsgruppe im Rat für Strafverfolgung hat sich auch schon wieder getroffen und Deutschland hat keine neue Positionierung. Auch interessant.
Und das kann natürlich nochmal was ausmachen, weil wir haben dann halt Österreich und Deutschland.
Irland ist jetzt auch dagegen, so wie es aussieht. Die Niederlande gegebenenfalls auch. Und da haben
dann doch noch relativ viele Staaten im Rat, weil das EU-Gesetzgebungsprozess 101 das Ding
kann ja auch im Rad fallen, theoretisch. Wenn sie das denn wollen. Die Option gibt's auch noch.
Das erinnert mich immer, also wo das immer alles fallen kann und wie viele wichtige Hürden,
das Gesetz nimmt. Also wenn ich mir dann anschaue, wie wenig sich da am Ende noch dran ändert, dann erscheint mir dieser Prozess streckenweise ein bisschen gemästet.
Ein gemästeter Prozess scheint mir das zu sein. Aber es ist wahrscheinlich wichtig, dass nicht nur alles gesagt ist, sondern auch von allen auf diesen Weg.
Zumindest wenn ich mich an so andere große unschöne Gesetzesinitiativen erinnere, die wir begleitet haben, dann weiß ich, dass wir zum Beispiel mit Felix Rehda über Jahre gesprochen haben. Da wurde immer wieder eine wichtige Hürde und jetzt kann das aber doch noch in dem Rad und,
und am Ende ist es aber doch nicht gekippt.
Ja, ich glaube, das sind so zwei Sachen, über die man jetzt nachdenken muss.
Natürlich kann man irgendwie immer noch versuchen, mit den Ausschüssen irgendwie zu verhandeln
und zu reden, was auch gerade so ein bisschen schwierig ist, weil die machen gerade die ganze Zeit Anhörungen, aber im Geheimen.
Also normalerweise ist es auch häufig so, dass solche Ausschüsse, so wie bei uns im Bundestag der Digitalausschuss, Anhörungen hat, die öffentlich sind.
Und dann sieht man auch, welche Stakeholderinnen dann da aktiv sind und so weiter und so fort. Was die gerade machen, ist, dass die diese Hearings im Kreis der Shadows, also um noch,
ein Vokabel in den Ring zu schmeißen, also es gibt immer einen primären Berichterstatter für jedes Pfeil in dem Ausschuss und dann gibt es sogenannte Shadows, das heißt jede,
Partei schickt natürlich auch nochmal eine Berichterstatterin dahin.
Und das findet gerade auch hinter den Kulissen statt,
wo es einfach gar keine öffentliche Berichterstattung und Anhörung gibt. Und worüber wir uns jetzt Gedanken machen müssen, ist, kriegen wir irgendwie eine Mehrheit im Parlament.
Also man kann sich ja schon mal überlegen, im Zweifelsfall,
wer die Abgeordnete für seinen Wahlkreis oder ihren Wahlkreis ist.
Und ob die vielleicht nicht komplett blöd ist und ob man vielleicht mit denen noch reden kann.
Ja, das stimmt. Der Vorteil, dass die Koalitions-, die Fraktionsdisziplin insgesamt so ein bisschen,
weniger groß geschrieben wird auf EU-Ebene, als sie es in den meisten nationalen Parlamenten getan wird. Das heißt, da hat man eine größere Chance als wenn man jetzt in Deutschland irgendwie seine Abgeordnete anruft,
die weiß im Zweifelsfall überhaupt nicht, wovor die Rede ist und lässt sich irgendwann,
also wenn die mal überhaupt zur Abstimmung geht.
Ja gut, ich würde jetzt nicht behaupten, dass das der WU-Parlament anders ist.
Ja, aber wie ist das immer? Die haben dann von ihren Mitarbeitenden so den Zettel. Dann müssen die ja alle mit der Hand abstimmen.
Aber ja.
Da gab es letztens auch, da haben die Schweden sich dann da verklickt oder so. Da haben die one-off gestimmt.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch total krass. Also, ich weiß nicht, hast du diese Abstimmzettel schon mal gesehen? Genau, das steht dann einfach, also, das ist einfach so eine Liste von zig Sachen, also auch immer nur so die Titel von den Sachen.
Ich glaube, ich habe mal einen gesehen, aber das ist lange her.
Das ist einfach so ein DIN A4-Blatt, wo dann drauf steht, hier, jetzt, dann da, dann da, Da da da da da da.
Und dann steht da basically, schreib dir dann deine Mitarbeitende daneben so ja, nein, vielleicht welchen Knopf du drücken sollst.
Ja, so erwarte ich das auch, eine ordentliche Vorarbeit, dass ich dann da sitze und wenn
ich da drei Knöpfe habe, muss mir mein Team schreiben, wann ich welchen Knopf drücken muss. So stelle ich mir das vor.
Ja, dann verrutscht du um eine Zeile.
Ja, dann ist das schlecht, dann müssen die im größeren Zeilenabstand machen oder zum Beispiel mal die Excel-Tabelle ordentlich formatieren. Daher auch zum Beispiel hier wie in diesem Überwachungs-Exil-Sheet da durchaus mal die Zeilen abwechselnd schattieren oder so.
Ja, aber One-Off-Stimmen ist schlecht. Aber weißt du, heute ist übrigens auch das ein Logbuch-Netzpolitik-Dauerbrenner-Thema.
Heute ist drei Jahre Brexit.
Ich habe heute so ein total geniales Meme gesehen.
Kennst du im Londoner Naturkundemuseum gibt es doch dieses große Dino-Skelett mit dem langen Hals.
Dinosaurier. Ja, mit dem langen Hals.
Und dann kennst du doch diese Dinos, die wie so ein aufblasbarer Luftballon sind. Weißt du, wie sie so ein bisschen verarmt aussehen?
So die T-Lufbar haben diese T-Rex-Kostüme und dieses Meme war wirklich basically so über dem diesem Dinos gestern wir once were the british empire now we are this.
Also echter Dino jetzt oder Luftballon? Ja, boah, die sind geil!
Diese Kostüme sind schon ganz cool.
Ich finde die total witzig. Wir haben da mal großen Spaß mit gehabt in einem Park in Berlin, wo eine Freundin an ihrem Geburtstag so ein Ding dabei hatte.
Ein bisschen laut, weil da ist so eine Pumpe drin, die den T-Rex die ganze Zeit aufbläst.
Aber großen Spaß mit gehabt. Gute Erinnerung an einen blauen T-Rex beim Thai-Markt in Berlin, in Schöneberg.
Ja, aber genau, jetzt haben unsere britischen Freundinnen und Freunde, die haben doch bestimmt nicht solche Chat-Kontrollen-Scheiße am Schuh.
Nee. Also weißt du, was das Tolle an dem Brexit ja ist?
Dass dadurch natürlich die Rechtsprechung vom Europäischen Gerichtshof nicht mehr für die gelten.
Und damit haben sie wieder ihr komplettes System von es gibt eigentlich keine Verfassung und wir können machen, was wir wollen, solange,
nicht irgendein Bauer sich vor 480 Jahren mal mit anderen Bauern darüber geeinigt hat, dass man erst zwei Steine auf einen Insornuntergang werfen muss oder so was.
Die haben doch irgendwie so ein ganz komisches...
Ja, das weiß ich gar nicht, aber das Verbot der allgemeinen Überwachungspflichten,
gilt halt nicht mehr für die.
Und was die jetzt gebaut haben, ist die Chat-Kontrolle auf Steroiden, würde ich sagen.
Das heißt, Online-Safety-Billen. Ich habe da irgendwie vor ein paar Wochen auch schon mal drüber getwittert, weil das wirklich die britische Version der Chat-Kontrolle ist.
Und das ist auch deswegen relevant, weil bei denen ist das schon durchs House of Commons, also das sind die gewählten Repräsentanten, gegangen und ist jetzt im House of Lords.
Das sind die nicht gewählten Repräsentanten. Mir hat sich noch nicht genau erschlossen, wie sich das zusammensetzt, aber da wird es gerade diskutiert. Und wenn alles glatt läuft, dann wird das im Juni in Kraft treten.
Und was sie da machen wollen, ist, dass Internet kindersicher.
Und das heißt, es geht nicht nur um Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellung, sondern es geht um jede Form von harmful Content.
Und dann geht es auch nicht nur um illegal harmful Content, sondern um legal but harmful Content.
Also irgendwas, was auf kinderverstörend wirken könnte.
Und das zu verhindern befähigt sie wozu oder berechtigt sie dann was zu tun?
Ja, das ist auch spannend. Die sind noch ein bisschen schlauer als die EU-Politikerinnen gewesen.
Die haben nämlich nirgendwo reingeschrieben, dass sie irgendwie interpersonelle Kommunikation überwachen wollen.
Sondern die haben einfach nur gesagt, Content, dass der privat und öffentlich kommuniziert wird.
Ah! Ah!
Also alles eigentlich. Und was sich jetzt da abgespielt hat, was wirklich total abgefahren.
Ah!
Ist. Also illegal content ist bei denen auch zum Beispiel Unterstützung von illegaler Migration.
Und deswegen kam diese Geschichte auf, dass sie jetzt verbieten wollen, dass Bilder, die über,
den Ärmelkanal fahren, mit Booten von Geflüchteten zensiert werden müssen, weil das ja illegaler
Content ist.
Okay, aber das kann man in Großbritannien ernsthaft debattieren, sowas.
Ah!
Offensichtlich, ja. Also da macht die Arbeit, die wir jetzt zur Tet-Kontrolle machen, die Open Rights Group.
Und die sind gerade auch dabei, sind da auch echt total am rotieren, genau das gleiche wie wir auch, um da irgendwie noch den schlimmsten Kram rauszubekommen. Aber das sieht echt zappenduster aus.
Und das Schlimme ist, das ist auch nur so ein, weißte, das ist nur so ein Sklett, das ist alles total weich und unausführlich. Und da steht dann halt drin, dass das Office of Communication, die Kurzform davon ist Ofcon,
das ist so ein bisschen wie unsere Landesmedienanstalten, kann man sich das vorstellen,
dann nachträglich, wenn das Gesetz in Kraft getreten ist, festlegen kann, wie die genaue Durchsetzung und die genaue Definierung des Gesetzes weiter erfolgt.
Also es ist völlig abgefahren.
Also man entscheidet ein Gesetz und überlässt dann eigentlich quasi die ermächtigte Behörde,
das genau nochmal auszuspezifizieren, was sie dann möchte.
Ja, genau. Und die soll dann auch noch Technologien natürlich bereitstellen und einkaufen und,
Listen pflegen und so. Ist ja klar.
Okay, warum interessiert uns das? Ich meine, die Briten haben es nicht anders gewollt, und ich habe auch wenig mit.
Naja, also ich glaube, wenn man sich an das Netzdurchsetzungsgesetz in Deutschland erinnert,
wie es damals in der Originalform in Kraft getreten ist, haben ja super viele Staaten das einfach von uns kopiert.
Und gerade Staaten, die so eh auf so einem Trip waren, besonders gerne.
Und dieses Online-Safety-Bill ist halt einfach so schön weich und unspezifisch, dass man
das super copy-pasten kann. Und das ruft natürlich die gleichen Menschen, die jetzt mit der Chat-Kontrolle hantieren,
auf den Plan, sich das als Vorbild zu nehmen.
So was machen Politikerinnen ja gerne. Weil wenn die Briten das können, dann können wir das ja auch.
Ja, die Briten als Vorbild, da sind wir gut mitgefahren.
Oh man, ich hab im Riesentisch ganz nicht anders angewiesen, als du gerade von den Dinosaurierkostümen sprachst.
Ich musste doch noch mal gucken, was so eins kostet. Ey, ich hab echt ein ganz cooles gefunden.
Ich wollte dich auch schon fragen, ob das schon auf deiner Wunschliste ist.
Es ist natürlich schon auf meiner Watchliste. Da reitet man auf dem T-Rex. Okay, das ist schon krank. Muss man schon sagen. Also da haben sie sich was bei gedacht.
Oh, sehr schön. LNP 500 würde ich sagen. Wir brauchen vielleicht noch so Dino zu den Einhornstandarte, Dino-Standarte.
Ja, ich finde das gut.
Das wäre doch mal was.
Einhorn-Standarte gibt es vielleicht auch in Neuigkeit. Aber ja, stimmt, vielleicht gibt es auch ein Einhorn-Kostüm.
Inflatable Einhorn-Kostüm.
Die gibt's bestimmt.
Oh, und dann kannst du die Tattoos dann auch mit einem Adding draufmalen.
Ja, mal schauen, was da noch, was da noch, was sich da vielleicht noch tut. Aber ja, inflatable einhorn doch ist sogar günstiger als der t-rex hier guck mal original inflatable
nur für erwachsene ok ok das schicke ich dir auch mal aber das glaube ich mit der sendung.
Einhörner nur für Erwachsene.
Weiter machen aus gibt einen einhorn also da will ich bei der nächsten live sendung würde ich das aber gerne spätestens sehen.
Also ich würde sagen, also wenn du, ich würde das Einhorn anziehen, du kannst ja den Dino,
Das ist wahrscheinlich nur unpraktisch mit einem Mikro.
Ja, das ist ja auch wie ein Einhorn, so deutsche Strafverfolgungsbehörden, die Ermittlungserfolge.
Ja, aber das klappt ja hier. Das ist vom Sound her wahrscheinlich ein bisschen belastend,
wenn da dieser Föhn, der läuft ja die ganze Zeit. Das Ding wird ja die ganze Zeit aufgeblasen. Na ja, okay. Bleiben wir mal hier kurz beim Thema. Und zwar...
Ja, es gab eigentlich zwei interessante News aus dem Bereich des Hacking in der vergangenen Woche. Ich fange mal mit meinem Lieblingsthema an. Killnet. Großes Thema, nachdem die.
Haben.
In Deutschland dann die Bereitstellung von vier, zehn Wildkatzen für die Ukraine irgendwie verkündet hat, haben sich russische Hacker darüber beklagen, darüber geärgert und die Gruppe Killnet, von der ich
jetzt nicht unbedingt was wusste, hat dann also zum Angriff auf die deutsche Wirtschaft gerufen. Da gab es dann unterschiedliche Journalistinnen und Journalisten, die darüber berichtet haben,
dass sie ja in der Telegram-Gruppe von dieser Hacker-Gruppe sind, wo ich so dachte, aha,
uiuiui, ne? Ist ja schon mal spannend. Das werden ja seriöse Hacker sein, wenn die in ihrer Telegram Gruppe schon von irgendwelchen fachfremden Journalisten durchgesetzt sind.
Und ja, dann haben die offenbar ein paar Denial-of-Service-Angriffe auf ein paar Webseiten gelauncht. Und einige der betroffenen Unternehmen haben das dann erst, also dass ihre Website down war, haben die erst erfahren, dadurch dass,
diese Journalistinnen sie dann angesprochen haben. So weißt du, da ruft die Presse bei dir an.
Ja, hallo, Ihre Website ist nicht erreichbar. Ja, stimmt. Ja, ich rufe doch mal an. So was von egal, ja. Aber das hat sie natürlich, weil sie jetzt die Zeit investiert hat und weil
sie jetzt als Journalisten erzählen wussten, dass sie in der Telegram-Gruppe von den russischen,
Hackern sind, musste das natürlich trotzdem überall erzählt werden. Das war also ganz
... Es ist immer ganz nett, wenn in diesen IT-Security-Themenbereich Leute vordringen, die jetzt da noch nicht so die Grundausbildung absolviert haben. Aber das nur am Rande. Jetzt.
Wurde die Seite von der Ransomware-Gang Hive offline genommen bzw. deren Hidden Service beschlagnahmt. Das heißt, es gibt wieder einen Neuzugang in meiner Sammlung der Domains
Seizure Pages. Ich habe ja mal irgendwann angefangen, immer wenn da so eine Zensurseite,
wenn da so ein Hidden Service gesiezt wird, das, was die Polizeibehörden dann dorthin machen. Das sammel ich. Ist übrigens nicht vollständig und Pull Requests sind jederzeit
willkommen. Also gibt es jetzt einen Neuzugang, weil jetzt der Hidden Service von Hive offline genommen wurde. Und das ist ja erstmal, kann man sagen, ist das eigentlich eine positive,
Entwicklung, wenn Ransomware-Gangs das Handwerk gelegt wird.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das hier tatsächlich der Fall ist.
Also Hive war eine Ransomware-Gruppe, die Unternehmen infiltriert hat. Dann klassische Vorgehensweise ist, sich irgendwie Domänenadministrationsrechte zu holen.
Man befällt erstmal einen Rechner, hofft darauf, dass man auf dem Zugänge, woanders hin findet, oder ein schlechtes lokales Admin-Passwort, um dann irgendwie durch weitere Ärgernisse,
eine Perspektive zu haben, das Active Directory zu übernehmen.
Einfachstenfalls, indem sich ein AD-Administrator auf dem befallenen Rechner einloggt oder in anderen Fällen dadurch, dass man sich eines Nutzeraccounts bemächtigt, der einen.
Pfad dahin hat, Domänenadmin-Rechte zu bekommen.
Das ist ein eigener Expertisebereich Active Directories zu übernehmen, der aber erlernbar ist und weil es relativ wenige Fehler gibt, die relativ viele machen, kann das auch relativ
erfolgreich durchgeführt werden. Na ja, dann bist du Domädenadmin, dann guckst du mal, wohin die Backups gehen und dann gibst du halt dem Backup-Server den Befehl zur Selbstzerstörung und dann rollst du per Gruppenrichtlinie,
deine Ransomware auf alle Rechner in der Domäne aus oder auf die entscheidenden
neuereigischen Punkte, zum Beispiel den Fileserver oder sonstiges. Während du das machst, exfiltrierst du schon mal ein bisschen Daten, um die.
Unternehmen, sollte es dir nicht gelingen, alle Dateien zu verschlüsseln und das Unternehmen so lahm zu legen, das Unternehmen dann außerdem oder ergänzend noch mit der Veröffentlichung
dieser Daten zu erpressen. So sehr schnell erzählt das Geschäftsmodell Ransomware über das wir bei Logbuch Netzpolitik auch glaube ich seit 2015, 2016 regelmäßig berichten. So, jetzt unterhalten die,
also damit du so etwas machen kannst, unterhältst du einen Hidden Service, über den du im Prinzip Prinzip zwei Dinge tust oder mehrere Hidden Services, über die du zwei Dinge tust. Erstens.
Du unterhältst diese Leaking-Page, weil durch den Hidden Service kannst du sicherstellen, dass der Server nicht so schnell aus dem Regal gezogen wird. Und zweitens nutzt du diesen oder
einen weiteren Hidden Service auch zur Kommunikation mit deinen Zielpersonen, um denen dann eben zu sagen, ja hier, du musst so und so viel Bitcoin da und dahin, dann wird dir der Schlüssel freigegeben oder oder oder.
Und jetzt wurden...
Wurde diese Gruppe gehackt.
Und zwar hat sich das FBI im Juli 2022 Zugang zu dem Kontrollzentrum dieses Netzwerks verschafft. Und damit haben sie dann schon mal die Software-Schlüssel erlangen können,
um die gesperrten Daten von Opfern weltweit zu entschlüsseln.
Also klar, am Ende ist das ein relativ einfacher Online-Shop, der einfach schaut ist auf den Bitcoin-Wallet, wo ich das haben will, das Geld eingegangen.
Wenn das der Fall ist, dann gebe ich hier den Key frei. Das heißt, diese Daten oder dieser Decrypter, üblicherweise kriegst du einen für unterschiedliche,
Betriebssysteme und Architekturen, was weiß ich, 32, 64 Bit und so weiter, da kriegst du alles fertig frei aus.
Die liegen ja schon auf dem Server, die werden halt nur erst nach Zahlung freigegeben. Das heißt, wenn du da so das Kontrollzentrum darauf Zugriff erlangst, dann kannst du diese Daten darunter laden und die den Betroffenen potenziell kostenlos zur Verfügung stellen.
Das hat das FBI gemacht. Und jetzt dann auch diesen Server offline genommen. Und rühmen sich also, wir haben die Hacker mit legalen Mitteln gehackt und den Spieß umgedreht.
Wie legal das war, wird man sehen, kommt halt darauf an, welche Methoden sie genutzt haben.
Als ich das letzte Mal geguckt habe, war Hacking not allowed in the Netherlands, aber die haben es offenbar legale Mittel fürs Hacking gefunden.
Was aber sie nicht geschafft haben, ist, irgendjemanden mal zu verhaften. Denn sie sagen jetzt, ja wir ermitteln noch und alle die damit zu tun haben, sollten sich Sorgen machen.
Aber letztendlich ist sie nur gelungen, dass sie halt diese Seite aufleihen genommen haben. Was nicht schlecht ist, weil nach meinem Verständnis war das eine leaking site.
Nach meinem Verständnis haben sie damit die Decryption Keys da raus bekommen.
Das ist schon mal alles ganz gut.
Aber was machen jetzt diejenigen, die mit die By the Hive oder mit the Hive gearbeitet haben?
Die werden natürlich jetzt einfach für andere Gruppen arbeiten. Insbesondere ist es ja so, dass die großen Gruppen zumindest ohnehin so ein Affiliate-Modell haben.
Das heißt, die stellen ihre Leaking-Infrastruktur, die stellen ihre Software und die sagen dir dann,
Pass auf, wenn du irgendwie was schaffst, damit jemanden zu infizieren, irgendein Unternehmen zu kompromittieren und den Kram auszurollen und die Zahlen am Ende, dann machen wir einen fairen Deal.
Und dann kriegst du halt Prozente davon, die eben dann auch auszuhandeln sind. Das heißt, die haben längst im Prinzip, wie würde man das sagen, hier wie Uber.
Ransomware as a Service.
Uber ist, ja genau, die sind Ransomerseservice, ja. Also Uber vermittelt dir ja in die, eine selbstständige Fahrdienstleister, ja.
Und Lieferando und Volt vermitteln dir Nahrungsmittelkuriere, ja. ist ja alles selbstständige, freischaffende.
Leute, damit sie die nicht sozial versichern müssen, so ungefähr arbeitet Hive auch.
Und das heißt, es ist relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass hier mit dieser Bande oder auch Leuten, die an diesen Angriffen beteiligt waren, nachhaltig das Handwerk gelegt wird, wenn die nicht in Knast sind.
Weil die werden jetzt nicht aufhören und sagen, oh shit, jetzt muss ich irgendwie bei McDonald's arbeiten, um meinen Ferrari zu tanken, sondern die werden natürlich einfach,
als Affiliates für andere Gruppierungen arbeiten.
Besonders schön fand ich dieses Logo vom BKA, was sie so auf Flashy FBI-mäßig gebaut haben. Hast du das gesehen?
Die haben immer so geile Sachen. Wenn man sich die Evolution der Domains Seizure Pages anschaut, in diesem Fall haben sie ja sogar, also meistens machen sie ja irgendwie so ein Bild hin, wo sie auch, wo da auch,
glaube ich, so nur die Besten der Besten bei der Polizei dran dürfen.
Und das ist in meiner Wahrnehmung das Erste, was ein animiertes GIF hat.
Diese ganze Webseite ist eigentlich nur ein GIF und das hat drei Phasen, nämlich einmal, dass der Text da in Englisch steht, dann einmal so ein weißer Blitz für eine halbe Millisekunde
oder was? Und dann der Text in Chirilisch. Also das ist schon ganz, ganz advanced. Die haben ja
den kompletten Textstack des Web 1.0 mit all seinen interaktiven Technologien genutzt. Also
da ist richtig Musik drin in dieser Geschichte. Naja, also das wird weiterhin ein Problem sein, und wenn man Unternehmen ein Rat geben darf, mehrere einfache Ratschläge, dann wäre das,
gebe ich mal hier kurz noch mit. Backup-Server nicht in der Domäne, also es darf nicht so sein, dass ein Domänenadmin die Backups löschen darf, der muss davon getrennt sein. Wir wollen möglichst
eine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung, insbesondere für Fernzugänge haben. Es gibt die Microsoft.
Local Administrator Password Solution Labs, mit der man eben sicherstellen kann, dass jeder Rechner ein stetig gewechseltes, lokales Adminpasswort hat, sodass die Leute nicht das, was nämlich
sonst Unternehmen tun oder Administratorinnen tun, dass sie einfache lokale Adminpasswörter vergeben. Das will man auch nicht haben. Und vielerlei mehr, um sich gegen solche Angriffe zu schützen. Denn Ich werde ja nicht müde, zu betonen, diese Masche funktioniert jetzt nunmehr seit sieben,
acht Jahren enorm gut und ist ein Wachstumsbereich in der kriminellen Wirtschaft.
Im Prinzip das primäre Betätigungsfeld von kriminellen Hackern. Und die schnappen sich ein Unternehmen nach dem anderen.
Und das ist äußerst unangenehm, wenn man da als Unternehmen betroffen ist.
Und ich glaube, das kann man günstiger vermeiden, als es, wenn man betroffen ist, aufzuräumen. Insofern würde ich jedem Unternehmen dazu raten, mal in ein brauchbares Wiederanlaufkonzept,
und die einfach nur klassische, einfache Schutzmaßnahmen zu investieren.
Wo man auch noch investieren könnte, wäre in coole Projekte für Leuchtturmprojekte in einer Stadt.
Das ist auch so ein Feld, in das man investieren könnte, oder?
Ja, aber man sollte dann mal gucken, wie das dann so mit so Namensrechten und so ist, ne?
Ja, die muss man sich leider sichern. Wir haben über den Fall hier schon mal gesprochen,
den Fall des Verschwörhauses in Ulm, wo ich anfangs diesen Namen so relativ eindeutig fand, dass der jetzt nicht von der Ulmer Stadtverwaltung kommt. Aber irgendwas mit,
Thema Verschwör gibt es in Ulm. Wurde ich da aufgeklärt. Aber also was ist da passiert?
Da haben ein paar engagierte Menschen der Community einen Hacker- und Hacker-Making-Space gebaut und den Verschwörhaus genannt und dann hat die Stadt Ulm das irgendwie gut gefunden und.
Irgendwie da drum herum noch ein bisschen was gebaut und erst mal gesagt total toll und dann haben sie die aber irgendwie rausgeworfen, den Namen für sich beansprucht. Also das Projekt lief,
ursprünglich unter Stadtlabor und dann haben die Aktivistinnen gesagt, Verschwörhaus ist doch viel cooler. Dann haben sie diesen Namen gegen den Widerstand der Stadt durchgesetzt und dann hat die Stadt irgendwann gesagt,
boah das läuft so gut, da sagen wir jetzt mal, wir sichern uns die Rechte,
beim europäischen Markenamt für Verschwörhaus und das Logo.
Mir war auch gar nicht klar, dass sie es gegen den Willen der Stadt durchgesetzt haben.
Das ist ja dann noch viel abstruse, dass sie jetzt auf einmal sagen,
ah, nee, jetzt funktioniert das ja, nee, jetzt kaufen wir das doch. Das ist ja völlig absurd.
Ja, die mussten erst überzeugt werden, das Projekt so zu nennen.
Dann haben sie es so genannt. Dann hat die Stadt sich quasi die Markenrechte gesichert. Und dann hat der Verein Widerspruch dagegen eingelegt, dass die Stadt ihren Namen als,
Marke registriert.
Und dann hat die Stadt gesagt, naja, Leute, wenn ihr hier weitere Nutzungsrechte von den Räumlichkeiten haben wollt, dann nehmt ihr mal schön den Widerspruch zurück.
Daraufhin hat die Community gesagt, nee, das ist nun mal unsere Mark und nicht eure, also nehmen wir auch den Widerspruch zurück.
Daraufhin hat dann die Stadt Ulm die Schlösser zum Verschwörhaus tauschen lassen.
Also wie kannst du so bescheuert sein als Stadtohrheber? Und jetzt leider haben sie jetzt, also der Verein hat dann, ne, dann hat die Stadt auf
Unterlassung gegen die Verschwörhaus-Community geklagt, die haben aber wiederum eine Wiederklage erhoben, dann hat die Stadt aber den Streitwert sechsstellig angesetzt, sodass das Verfahren direkt beim Landgericht Stuttgart landet.
Und jetzt hast du halt Leute, die ein Communityprojekt gemacht haben, Hand in Hand mit der Stadt, bis die Stadt die bescheuerte Idee hatte, denen ihren Markennamen klauen zu wollen.
Und jetzt muss, also wie kannst du so mit deinen Aktiven in deiner Stadt umgehen?
Ja, es gibt Lisanne Wolters, die das kommentiert. Das ist ein absoluter Engagementkiller. Also sie sind auf der Suche nach einem neuen Haus, haben außerdem ein potenzielles finanzielles
Risiko von bis zu 30.000 Euro. Wenn sie durch alle Instanzen gehen müssen und der, sei mal Aber das Verhältnis zur Stadt ist inzwischen ruiniert.
Man fragt sich auch, was erlaube Ulm? Überleg mal, wem willst du denn als nächstes sagen,
hey Leute, wollt ihr nicht ein bisschen Engagement in unserer Stadt zeigen?
Und die Leute sagen, naja, die letzten, die hier wirklich was Cooles gebaut haben, den habt ihr versucht, das zu klauen und die nachher mit Streitwert im sechsstelligen Bereich,
komplett versucht zu ruinieren.
Also, da könnte man eigentlich mal so ein paar Ransomware-Typen, die jetzt zuletzt Potsdam plattgemacht haben, die könnten sich mal...
Zweimal, oder?
Ja, zweimal. Komm, zweimal auf Potsdam ist unfair. da besser mal in Ulm gucken. Ich verlinke mal ulm.de. So, login ulm.de. Admin. Admin.
Uiuiui, nicht dass dann jetzt hier das BSI die Tweets zu dieser Folge sperrt oder so.
Nee, hat nicht geklappt.
Naja, aber vielleicht finde ich das nicht. Unglaublich.
Vielleicht verschwörhausatmen? Verschwörst du?
Also wirklich, es ist ja, aber kannst du dir das, kannst du dir das, da muss doch irgendjemand, irgendjemand in der Stadt Ulm, muss doch irgendwann einmal also sich das angucken, Zeitung aufmachen und sagen, Leute seid ihr bescheuert, hört auf.
Oder? Also das kann doch so nicht sein.
Ja, also ich komme da überhaupt nicht drüber hinweg, weil vor allen Dingen, wenn du auch so einen Hacker-Space,
mit wirklich guten Leuten, die ja auch wirklich viel, ich glaube auch viel so Kinder- und
Jugendarbeit vor allen Dingen gemacht haben. Hä? Also, das ist, ja, weiß ich gar nicht, was man dazu noch sagen muss.
Also dazu gibt es einfach nichts zu sagen, außer einfach nein.
Also. Also...
Das war's für heute.
Es ist wirklich... Verschwörhaus.de gehört also noch dem Verein.
Dann gibt es den Verschwörhaus.ev. Und dann gibt es Ulm.de, das Verschwörhaus. Die werben da auf.
Der Kreativraum.
Ein offenes Haus. Das geht im Verschwörhaus.
Und wer hat noch damit, dass sich das Jugendhackt-Lab im Verschwörhaus getroffen hat? Da habe ich ja eine Idee, wer das gemacht hat. Oh man, ey.
Tja, also wirklich faszinierend. Also mein Tipp an die Stadt Ulm wäre Leute. Kommt mal klar.
Entschuldigung schreiben inklusive neuer 3D-Drucker oder so, würde ich vorschlagen.
Ja, also so mal richtig echt sorry. Oh man, ey, das ist, aber komm.
Oh, und die sind jetzt erfreulich?
Okay, aber ich glaube, das war's an unerfreulichen Nachrichten für heute. Kommen wir zu den Kurznachrichten.
Nee, leider nicht.
Ich muss noch ganz kurz sagen, am 21. März wird es dann eine Entscheidung in dem Verschwörhaus in diesem Verfahren geben.
Zu kürzeren unerfreulichen Nachrichten.
Als ich das, ich kann jetzt leider nicht mehr sagen, als ich das letzte Mal hier war, weil ich jetzt öfter hier bin. Ja, also Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtete über das European
Health Data Space, was noch nicht so wirklich viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat. Also ich,
sag mal, ich mach's jetzt mal ganz kurz, wenn ihr die längere Form haben wollt, ist es,
die LNP, in der ich letztes Jahr zu Gast war. Es geht wieder um Zentralisierung von Gesundheitsdaten.
Wissen wir ja alle, total wichtige Sache. Und das will die EU jetzt auch auf EU-Ebene
schaffen und auch so eine Nutzung von anonymisierten, pseudonymisierten Gesundheitsdaten für Forschung
und so was ermöglichen. Und das ist auch eine Sache, wo die Entscheidung in diesem Jahr
noch fallen könnte. Die Timeline sieht ganz ähnlich aus wie bei der Chat-Kontrolle. Also
na, wobei vielleicht wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen schneller, dass sie den Report der,
jeweiligen zuständigen Ausschüsse schon vor dem Sommer rausbringen werden und in den Ausschüssen,
abstimmen werden und dass er dann sozusagen nach der Sommerpause direkt ins Parlament geht.
Nein, leider nicht. Also ich habe das letzte Mal hier… Also das letzte Mal hatte ich.
Okay, das ist keine gute Nachricht.
Hast du vielleicht aus der Schweiz eine gute Nachricht?
Darüber gesprochen, dass es in der Schweiz jetzt wohl auch Age-Verification geben wird Und das wurde auch in den Kommentaren nochmal völlig richtig eingeordnet. In der Schweiz
ist es ja so, dass solche Gesetzgebungsprozesse noch durch Volksabstimmungen aufgehalten werden
können. Damit so eine Volksabstimmung allerdings zustande kommt, muss man innerhalb von 100 Tagen 50.000 Unterschriften sammeln. Dazu hatten wir auch letztes Mal aufgerufen. Es hat leider
nicht gereicht. Das heißt, der Ausweiszwang in der Schweiz wird kommen.
Ja, ich sagte, die kommen von allen Seiten mit diesem ganzen Quatsch an und schaffen
uns dann durchzukommen.
Ja, Scheiße.
Einfach so jetzt.
Und wie, wie, wie, so haben die, woran lag es, dass sie jetzt, ja sie sagen, erreichen die Zahl wohl nicht. Wieso ist denn das, also es wäre natürlich jetzt Okay, also tatsächlich mal wichtig zu... Woran hattet ihr legen?
Ich glaube an der Kurzfristigkeit und an der fehlenden Aufmerksamkeit für das Thema.
Also das ist halt so, es passiert so viel Mist gerade auf so vielen unterschiedlichen Ebenen,
du weißt gar nicht, wo du zuerst von gucken sollst. dann kommen dann halt solche Politikerinnen und sneaken sich dann irgendwie durch so eine Lücke durch. Ich bin nicht die Überbringerin.
Ich kann ja nicht mehr in Ruhe arbeiten, wenn viel zu tun ist. Okay. Hm.
Ja, ist denn irgendwie was Gutes noch? Irgendwas? Okay, dann.
Ah, das ist, das ist, ja, that's the spirit, can you see?
Also ich wäre gern häufiger die Überbringerin. Guter Nachrichten. Aber aktuell würde ich sagen, ist es noch in Arbeit.
Das ist ja, that's the spirit, Khaleesi. Ja, so will ich das hören.
Genau, du arbeitest noch dran. Also du machst quasi im Prinzip so diese ganze Chat-Kontrolle, schlechte Nachrichten machst du nur, damit wir uns dann am Ende oder zur Mitte des Jahres einfach unglaublich freuen, dass du eigenhändig die Kuh vom Eis geschoben hast.
Das finde ich spitze. Aber wir spoilern das nicht. sondern.
Vor allen Dingen, ich bin ja auch nicht alleine, das muss ich ja immer sagen.
Also wenn ihr denkt, dass ich schon ein EU-Policy-Nerd seid, dann habt ihr meine Kollegin Ella,
die in Brüssel für E3 sitzt und ganz, ganz tolle Arbeit macht, noch nicht erlebt. Ja, das ist meistens auch schon beeindruckend genug, glaube ich.
Dann verlinken wir mal Ella. Ich kenne sie nur schriftlich. Ich kriege immer.
Jakubowska, Senior Policy Advisor. Okay, können wir auch nochmal verlinken. So, dann sind wir so ein bisschen am Ende der Sendung, habe ich den Eindruck. Wir könnten noch, aber dafür
Ich kann ja jetzt hier nicht die Terminmelodie so gut einspielen, deswegen mach ich das mal ohne.
Ja, da musst du jetzt auch den Terminmelodie... Ja komm, jetzt sprich!
Der netzpolitische Abend ist zurück aus der Höhlen der Pause und findet statt am kommenden
Dienstag, das ist der 7. Februar, wie immer auf der Seabase. Es geht um Pressefreiheit in Zeiten des Krisen und um den Rechtsstreit mit Bayern um hoffnete Daten. Da ist unter
anderem der Liebe MD da. Die werden nämlich gerade von den Bayern verklagt. Und damit.
Das war jetzt albern.
Haben wir es mit den schlechten Nachrichten und der wundervollen musikalischen Unterlegung.
Das ist jetzt mal gespannt, ob das diesmal besser hinhaut mit dem Mixing. Ob man dich versteht oder mich versteht, weil das mit dem Einspielen der Terminmelodie
kriegen wir regelmäßig Ärger, weil auf Phonik das nachher nochmal irgendwie kaputt macht.
Also machen entweder die Melodie komplett weg oder zu laut. Da gab es auch in den vielen Kommentaren zur letzten Sendung wieder Klagen. Mal schauen, ob das besser klappt, wenn man selber macht.
Du hast ja in einer sehr angenehmen Lautstärke gesungen.
Ich glaube, wenn ich singe, ist angenehm einfach der falsche... das ist einfach das Wort angenehm, gehört da glaube ich nicht mit dazu.
Das ist so wie EU-Gesetzgebungsprozesse, meinst du?
Das passt nicht wirklich zusammen. Bist du denn auch da am 123. Netzpolitischen Abend?
Ich bin auf dem Easter Hack. Also ihr könnt mich auf dem Easter Hack treffen.
Ich muss jetzt gerade mal kurz gucken. 123 ist keine Primzahl.
Nein, eins ist keine Briefe.
123 ist keine Primzahl, kann man durch drei teilen natürlich.
Ja, also 120 kann man durch drei teilen, also kann man auch 123 durch drei teilen. Also 41, 3, 1 und 123 sind Teile von 123.
123 ist keine Primzahl.
Schade.
Okay, also haben wir darauf hingewiesen. Wann ist das denn? Also der hin? 7. Februar. Das ist immer Dienstags, ja. Da, nee, werde.
Ja. Ist das nicht der nächste Dienstag schon? Ja, ich glaube schon.
Nächste Woche Dienstag.
Ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Ja, aber irgendwann wird es schon hingehen. Und Michael Krall ist auf jeden Fall, Michael Krall und MD werden da auf jeden Fall ein schönes Thema behandeln.
Das andere Thema habe ich gerade nicht verstanden. Also ich muss ja singen.
Und ich musste lachen, das war das Problem. Es ging um Pressefreiheit in Zeiten des Krieges.
Okay, auch sicherlich ein Thema, was total gute Laune macht. Ja, ihr seht, das funktioniert bei uns weiterhin. Unser Geschäftsmodell ist stabil, schlechte Nachrichten angenehm verpackt.
Danke, dass du mit mir auch mal vorlieb genommen hast. Khaleesi hat mir viel Spaß gemacht und ich hoffe der Tim hat Spaß, das jetzt hier alles zu schneiden.
Ja, gerne wieder. Es bleibt spannend und geteiltes Leid, das halbes Leid.
So schlimm war es jetzt auch nicht.
Also du meinst jetzt mit dir oder die Nachrichten?
Das überlasse ich jetzt der Fantasie unserer Hörerinnen.
Dann würde ich sagen, tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao ciao!